Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch Emotes, long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Kappa Pog Champ, keep a forehead, Bible Thumb, Twitch Emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game
Forehead Swift Rage, PJ Salt and Failfish
Life was easy, spamming all the time
TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine
Twitchy Maltz, long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Capoponcham, keep a forehead, Bible thumb.
Twitchy Maltz, still hear his bark in the morning hour.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Pog is PogChamp, Cap is CapPog, Bible Thumb, Twitchy Mode, Twitter Fans, Twitchy Mode,
Twitchy Mods.
So.
Ups.
Äh.
Hat gerade irgendwie...
Okay.
Warum ist gerade der komplette Browser zugegangen?
Wobei wir können das auch einfach mal hier aufmachen.
Später gucken.
So, ja, also dann müssen wir mal, ganz wichtig, es ist Sonntag, das heißt wir müssen jetzt
unbedingt die Linux-Kiste mal updaten und rebooten.
Aber erstmal muss ich mal den Logitech-Tempel starten
Warum braucht eigentlich mittlerweile
Dieses komische Maustreiber-verkappte-Browser-Ding
Gefühlt eine halbe Stunde, um zu starten
Erinnert sich noch einer an die alte Logitech-Software
Die hast du angeklickt, die ist aufgegangen, konntest du sofort benutzen
Und sogar dieses Ding war früher schneller
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung, was die da treiben
Warum ist mittlerweile heute alles so super lahm und bloated?
Das ist echter Wahnsinn.
Einfach selbst programmieren.
Naja, also Hardware-Sachen sind natürlich schwierig.
Ja, was gibt da sonst nichts?
Es gibt doch nichts anderes.
Es gibt dieses alte, outdated Logitech-Ding, wo ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher bin, ob das überhaupt meine Hardware-Support ist.
ja das ist genauso wie du fragst ja okay was ist du hast ein klo der nicht
gefällt warum gehst du denn drauf ja weil ich kacken muss
hier bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig
so ich muss auch mal die lösungskiste starten wo wir gerade dabei sind und den
Dance-Pepo, den
können wir ausmachen.
Linux-Mini-PC, jaja.
Was hat der eigentlich immer für Schmerzen, das OBS
da? Warum spackt denn das immer so rum?
Das will immer
nochmal extra neu gestartet
werden. Es ist nicht
written in Rust. Leute, es gab
früher Software, habe ich gehört.
Ich war da sogar live dabei.
Die war nicht written in Rust.
Und die ist trotzdem instant gestartet.
Zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen unfair der Vergleich, wobei eigentlich gar nicht unfair.
Wenn ihr Windows 95 oder Windows 98 oder meinetwegen auch Windows ME in einer VM installiert,
also das heißt, ihr setzt nochmal Virtualisierung dazwischen und ihr klickt irgendwas an,
Das ist
Nicht messbar
Die Verzögerung
Würde ich mal behaupten
Die das braucht bis das offen ist
Warum muss es genau diese Maus
Achso okay
Das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal checken
Ups
Ich muss jetzt erstmal vom Hardwarekauf checken
Ob der Treiber kacke ist oder nicht
Was natürlich schwierig zu wissen ist
Bevor ich die Hardware eigentlich hab
Weil wie soll ich den Treiber testen, bevor ich die Hardware habe?
Ganz einfach abgesehen, man wusste ja, dass es früher auch gescheit funktioniert hat.
Und außerdem ist die Maus richtig nice.
Das ist nämlich eine kabellose Maus mit einem Mauspad, was die Maus auflädt.
Habe ich sogar noch nicht gesehen, bis dahin.
Ich habe es ja auch schon ein paar Jahre.
Ist eigentlich ziemlich nice, das Ding.
Aber der Treiber ist richtig...
Oder ist ja nicht immer der Treiber, dieses Management-Gui ist richtig kacke.
Ne, das ist keine unpopular
Opinion, das ist so
Du kannst alles in jeder Sprache
Eklig und schlecht programmieren
Das ist allgemein bekannt
Aber
Klickt mal
Installiert euch Windows 95 in der VM
Das müssen wir mal zumachen
Das auch
Und klickt mal was an, das ist instant da
Das ist schneller da
Das ist schneller da als das Terminal hier auf Linux
Ihr hört ja, ich drück jetzt und es ist instant da.
Aber das ist schneller.
Das ist schneller als da.
Als hier auf meinem Linux.
Das ist instant. Das ist so schnell, wie wenn ich ein LS eingebe.
So drückst du es, bam, ist es da.
Was? Was? Was?
Warum?
Was macht KDE da für einen Scheiß?
Ich will nicht die Developer Edition da haben.
Anpinnen.
Ich will...
Ich will das pinnen.
Genau, ich will den normalen Firefox.
Die Developer Edition will ich doch gar nicht.
Die Developer Edition, die brauche ich nur,
wenn ich mich in einem Dev-Container einloggen will.
Mit der Idee, dass man da den Link aufmacht.
Dass es halt in dem extra Browser aufgeht.
Ja.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, wollen wir mal gucken
Was sagt denn
Was sagt denn das Wetter, ich könnte aus dem Fenster
Gucken, Leute
Ich könnte aus dem Fenster gucken, aber alternativ
Wir können auch ein Command Line Tool aufrufen
Also ich würde sagen, Chat
Aus dem Fenster gucken
Versus Command Line Tool aufrufen
Was bevorzugt
Würdet ihr bevorzugen
Also ich bin da eindeutig beim Command Line Tool.
Also Fenster gucken ist outdated.
Ja, Steel Eye Tool.
Also.
Ah, guck mal.
Es ist sonnig mit ein paar kleinen Wölkchen.
Mal gucken, ob das stimmt.
Ich gucke jetzt mal aus dem Fenster.
Also Wolken sehe ich keine, aber Sonne ist da.
Oh, das heißt aber auch, wenn heute Sonne ist, ja.
Wenn heute, ups.
Wenn es heute sonnig ist.
Ist es denn den ganzen Tag? Ach komm, scheiß drauf, guck ich später.
Wenn es heute sonnig ist, heißt es, ich habe keine Ausrede, dass ich meinen Long Run machen muss heute.
Weil es ist Wochenende, schönes Wetter, es ist nicht zu warm.
Wird mal wieder Zeit.
Wobei ich nicht die Long Long Runde mache, sondern wahrscheinlich nur die kürzere Long Runde,
die dann irgendwie 11 Kilometer oder so ist.
Ganz schön kalt, stimmt.
Was war es denn für eine Temperatur?
Ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt.
7,4 Grad.
Ja, das ist doch so wunderbar.
Also, wenn ich fertig streamen bin,
dann ist es irgendwann, keine Ahnung,
halb eins oder so.
Oder eins oder irgendwas in dem Dreh.
Dann ist es bestimmt 14, 15 Grad.
Und wenn dann auch die Sonne scheint,
dann kann man sogar easy in kurzer Hose rennen.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber erstmal ganz wichtig
Update machen.
Yes.
Und wenn es gibt kein Kernel-Update,
das heißt im Endeffekt, ich muss noch nicht mal
mein Rechner neu starten.
Ja, dann halt kein Reboot.
Übrigens, Chat.
Wisst ihr, was mir da gerade
Auffällt?
Wartet mal, ich hab ne Idee
Wartet mal kurz
Ähm
Guckt mal
Was mir da gerade auffällt
Guckt mal, ich hab doch hier die Dinger
Ähm
Hier die Jetbrains IDE installiert
Über
Diese Jetbrains Toolbox
So, was ich noch nicht gemacht hab, ist, ich hab mich noch nicht
Eingeloggt
So, aber was man jetzt hier sieht, ist, wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise hier Rider starte oder irgendeins von diesen Ideen.
Übrigens dieses Mauszeige aufpumpen ist enorm pock.
Zwar relativ sinnloses Feature, aber nice, dass es geht.
So, und wenn ich das jetzt irgendwie starte oder wir starten GoLand, weil da weiß ich, dass ich ein Projekt habe.
Dann steht nämlich da, dass ich in einer Trial-Periode bin.
Irgendwo steht das jetzt gleich da.
Trial
Trial 3 Days
und ich bin nicht eingeloggt
das heißt doch im Endeffekt
dass die Informationen
dass ich eine Trial
Periode laufen habe
irgendwo in meinem
Heimatverzeichnis gespeichert
sein muss, das heißt wenn ich
das lösche
könnte ich unendlich lang die Trial
Extenden. Sehe ich das richtig?
Postchamp?
Jetzt müssen wir das nur noch finden,
wo das ist.
Bestimmt Config?
Ne, das läuft über eine Hardware-ID.
Ja, aber ich bin doch gar nicht eingeloggt.
Wo sollen die das denn speichern?
Oder meinst du, die machen tatsächlich
trotzdem Online-Verbindungen?
Auch, ob ich das will oder nicht.
Aber ich bin ja gar nicht eingeloggt.
Guck mal hier, Jet Brains.
Guck mal, da ist
Early Access.
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mal mache?
Also keine...
Ahnung, aber...
Das Teil kommuniziert regelmäßig.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Och, wirklich?
Naja.
Ich wollte das jetzt nämlich gerade mal umbenennen.
So, und jetzt...
Toolbox.
Nochmal gucken.
Was er jetzt sagt.
Gucken wir mal.
Force Champ?
Ach, fuck.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht.
Weil früher, also vor einigen Jahren ging das noch.
Da hat es das nämlich lokal gespeichert.
Reset JetBrains Trial
Linux
Kugeln wir mal danach
Moment, was ist das hier?
Aha, aha
Two years ago, das geht wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, oder?
Oder doch?
Das ist keine VM, das ist ja das Ding
Config Product
Ach Moment, die haben noch für die einzelnen Sachen
Golang, ne, ne haben sie nicht
Das ist outdated, das gibt es nicht mehr
Würde ich sagen
Guck
Config Product
Hier
Golang gibt es nicht
Okay, das ist outdated, das funktioniert nicht mehr
Was?
Punkt Java?
Ne
Punkt Java
User Prefs
User
Jet
Was zum Teufel
Was für Hacker mein Zeug ist das?
Leute.
Guck mal.
Geh mal hier User.
Wir machen das jetzt nochmal.
Ich muss das jetzt nochmal ausprobieren.
Wir gehen jetzt mal dahin.
Also A.G. nochmal Config.
Jetzt moven wir nochmal.
Jetbrains nach Bloop.
Und moven jetzt.
Ich move einfach die kompletten User Prefs nach Kekkel.
Okay, so und jetzt Toolbox.
Gucken, was er jetzt sagt.
Aha, guck mal da.
Lizenzstelz.
Goland.
By the way, warum ist das immer noch installiert?
Und, und Postchem, Postchem, Post...
Haaa?
Ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Trial is reseted!
Easy! Easy!
Easy.
Easy as fuck!
E-e-easy.
E-e-easy as fuck!
nice so ist das schön gut ich verliere jetzt die die die die settings ja aber
ganz ehrlich wen juckt ich habe kaum customized dabei das ja witzig
meine maus ist wieder so eklig da in der mitte
nice okay jetzt wirst du also lieber chat ich meine mal ganz davon abgesehen
Ich muss die Trial nicht resetten.
Ich habe einen All-Desktop-Pack.
Aber es hat mich jetzt einfach mal interessiert.
Wie das funktioniert.
Interesting.
Tja, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Wenn man das resettet.
Katzi
Mal ganz davon abgesehen
Würde ich trotzdem sagen
Wer das regelmäßig benutzt und damit sogar Geld verdient
Irgendeine Art und Weise
Der kann sich das ruhig kaufen
Weil so teuer ist das nämlich nicht
Also erstens
Für viele Jetbrains Sachen
Braucht man mittlerweile gar keine Lizenz mehr
Das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich besser als ich
Also IntelliJ geht ohne Lizenz
Rust Rover geht glaube ich auch ohne Lizenz
PyCharm
Geht glaube ich auch ohne Lizenz
Und ich glaube sogar Rider geht mittlerweile ohne Lizenz
Oder
Also sicher
Sicher bin ich mir bei IntelliJ und PyCharm
Rust Rover nicht
Rider glaube ich mittlerweile auch
Ja weil früher
Früher gab es PyCharm Community Edition
und IntelliJ Community Edition.
Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Rider ist auch kostenlos. Heißt im Endeffekt,
wenn ich Rider öffne,
dann
erzählt er mir auch nichts von Trial und sowas.
Also das meiste davon kann man ja
sogar for free benutzen.
Ja.
Und dazu kommt,
dass es auch,
wenn man damit sein Geld, oder wenn man nicht
unbedingt sein Geld, aber wenn man damit auch
irgendwie
Geld verdient.
Man könnte ja sagen, ich verdiene damit
Geld. Ich bin zwar nicht hauptberuflicher Entwickler,
aber ich streame ab und zu
und kriege da ein bisschen Kohle.
Letztendlich,
warum ist denn die Seite? Achso, das ist
wegen dem Dark wieder.
Das ist preislich auch gar nicht
so schlimm, das All Desktop Package.
For
Individual Use.
Guck mal.
Man bezahlt 299 Euro im Jahr
Und das geht dann runter
Bis auf 179 Euro im Jahr
Für ab dem dritten Jahr
Und ganz ehrlich
179 Euro im Jahr
Für das All Desktop Package
Das ist okay
Das kann man sich echt gucken
Warum haben wir kein Developer Emote
Kennst du ein gutes Developer Emote
Ach, hier steht es ja auch, guck mal.
Sealine, free for non-commercial use.
Data Grip, free for non-commercial use.
Goland kostet...
Ruby Mine ist free for non...
Rider ist free for non...
Rust Rover und Web Swap.
Also, guck mal, für das meiste brauchst du noch nicht mal mehr eine Lizenz mittlerweile.
Also, es sei denn, ihr macht jetzt was in Go.
Das muss man tatsächlich wohl lizenzieren.
Das ist aber, ohne Mist, Leute, jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, ne?
Goland ist das einzige hier von...
was ich regelmäßig benutze, was noch was kostet.
Theoretisch könnte ich downgraden auf GoLand only.
Einmal ganz davon abgesehen, streng genommen, hier steht ja non-commercial use,
streng genommen würde ich mal sagen, ist das ja sogar commercial use,
wenn ich damit Geld verdiene.
Das ist zwar nicht viel auf Twitch, aber ich meine, ist ja hier Streaming-Content
und da gibt es Subscriptions und Bits und alles.
Da könnte man sogar argumentieren, das ist commercial use.
Also behalte ich mal einfach hier mein All-Products-Pack.
Und logge mich
das nächste Mal ein.
Ah, ich muss Chaturino starten.
Kann man das da oben eigentlich ausblenden?
More.
Geht nicht.
Kann man nicht ausblenden.
War die Katze wieder da?
Ja, die ist fast jeden Tag mittlerweile da.
Äh.
Kein Bock, irgendwas zu partnershippen.
Selbst, selbst.
Wir waren davon abgesehen, die wollen das wirklich wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Aber.
Hätte ich auch keinen Bock.
Okay, wollen wir mal gucken, ob der Chat...
Ist das ein...
Was soll das sein?
Ein Developer-Emote?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Ne, da bräuchten wir, wenn schon...
Ne, ne, ne.
Da bräuchten wir...
Das finde ich schon mal nicht schlecht.
Aber ich hätte gerne die GIF-Variante, wo der klatscht.
Gibt es das vielleicht auch als Emote?
Ja, animiert finde ich auch.
Hier, warte mal.
Emote
Developers
Warmer
Gleich mal, gibt's
Great Gifts
Also, falls ihr irgendwie dieses
Das als GIF habt
Wo der klatscht, dann nehm ich das sofort
Bis dahin
Bis dahin können wir ja
Temporär
Bis wir das andere haben
kann man das temporär reinhauen
ich hab's ich hab's hinzugefügt
es ist groß geschrieben alles developers alles groß geschrieben
bisschen nostalgisch hier rein zu früher als beta viel und gott ging habe ich allerdings
etwas mehr verschafft ja gut da gut auf ich auf auf twitch war eigentlich noch nie als
funktioniert das funktioniert jetzt bei mir hier im chat funktioniert aus irgendwelchen
gründen nicht ich brauche kurz reloaden das war kurz gucken die welle pass hier hat es
doch nicht reloadet warum nicht also beim anderen chat funktioniert witzigerweise
Warum funktioniert es hier nicht? Hat das irgendwelche Emotes nicht eingeschaltet oder so?
Moment, Moment, Moment, wartet mal, wartet mal, wartet mal. Chat. Chat neu laden. Jetzt funktioniert
es hier unten auch im Chat. Also keine Ahnung, das braucht wahrscheinlich einfach ein bisschen
bis er das hier gecheckt hat. Chatterino, guckt Chatterino, checkt sofort. Developers, Developers,
developers ganz ehrlich wir waren die pressekonferenzen damals irgendwie lieber
der typ hat der kompletten dachschaden gehabt aber das war wenigstens noch
lustig und heute ist das alles diese ganzen präsentationen sind heute so auf
künstlich emotional gemacht ich habe euch ja letztens ich habe euch ja
letztens gezeigt noch mal die windows 11 präsentation der hat ja fast der hat ja
fast geweint ja ja sehr gut at to change im moment wie werden wir das im ort die
werler was klein geschrieben finde ich nicht gut dass das jemand eine gute idee
wie wir das im ort nennen können bei uns sind hier hier im channel
Devs? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Leute, Devs, das Wort,
das Wort, äh,
wir nennen es einfach
Developers großgeschrieben und ich mache das alte
wieder raus, das andere.
Ich mache das andere wieder raus.
Hier, Channels,
zack.
Habe ich wieder raus gemacht und jetzt nehme ich das hier
und mache großgeschrieben
Developers. Entwickler.
Das finde ich auch...
Die Developers.
Okay.
Jetzt aber.
Funktioniert.
Beste.
Mein Chat.
Mein Chat hat es noch nicht.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Mein Chat hat es noch nicht gecheckt hier unten.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Ich muss gerade nochmal
checken, ob es jetzt
ob der Chat es jetzt kapiert hat
Ja, gut
Geht und
Chatterino hat es auch kapiert
Exzellent, da muss man sagen
Chatterino ist wirklich eine gute Anwendung
Die lädt Emotes und sowas so on the fly
nach
Ja.
So, dann gucken wir doch mal,
was trendet denn
auf Shithub heute so?
Nicht heute,
weekly. Okay, gucken wir mal, was heute
trendet. Money Printer
V2.
Automate
the process of making money
online.
Vibe Coded.
Okay, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
ist das ein
YouTube
AI Slop
Erstellungstool.
Ja, oder?
Twitterbot, YouTube Shorts.
Ja, das ist ein
AI-Slop Content Creation Tool.
Ach du Kacke, hör mal bloß auf.
System D trendet
heute. 58 Sterne
today. System D.
Bestimmt, weil es ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit
die letzten Tage bekommen hat wegen
Age Verification. Mal gucken, ob da immer noch die...
Oh, meine Güte, Alter.
Wie die abgehen.
Ich hab ja gestern mich da schon
länger dazu ausgelassen, ne?
Zu Age Verification und sowas.
Wofür steht das D in System D?
Ich würd sagen Demon, wie bei allem anderen
Zeug, wo D hinten dran steht.
Aber
ich könnte jetzt nicht drauf wetten.
Trivi. Trivi ist nice.
kann man Source Codes scannen
und Container Images
und so Zeug, wobei Container Images bin ich mir ganz sicher
also du kannst
ähm
Terraform
Sachen scannen und so was
hier Code Repos, das ist eigentlich ganz nice
AI
AI.
Protobuff.
Äh, wahrscheinlich AI.
Generate any location from the real world in Minecraft.
Okay, das war ein cooles Projekt.
Nicht, dass ich großer Minecraft-Spieler wäre,
aber wenigstens mal was, was nicht AI ist, was trennt.
Die Frage ist, ist es vibe-coded?
Scheint nicht so.
Zumindest ist es nicht in den Contributors drin.
So, mehr trendet heute nicht.
Dann gucken wir mal, was trendet denn diese Woche.
Was soll denn das sein?
Mirofish, ist das AI?
Ist China...
Mirofish AI, okay.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Gibt es das auch auf Englisch?
Ja.
Next Generation AI Prediction Engine.
Okay.
AI.
Lightpanel.
Headless Browser designed for AI.
AI.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, wahrscheinlich AI, keine Ahnung, klingt aber auch nach AI.
Playstation 4 Emulator, so weit sind wir schon.
Playstation 4 Emulator for Windows, written in C++.
Nicht written in Rust.
Kann es denn jemals Blazingly Fast sein, Leute?
Early Playstation 4 Emulator.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich werden viele Spiele gar nicht drauf laufen.
Aber wir gucken mal kurz.
Source Code.
Okay, Common, das ist bestimmt ordentlich, halbwegs ordentlich.
Warum brauchen wir ein neues AIS, gibt es das nicht schon?
Hm, obviously, alles klar, da weißt du Bescheid.
Gut, Krypto-Sachen sind nie ordentlich und schön zu lesen.
Okay, String-Implementierung, alles klar.
Ist ja klar, jedes Projekt braucht natürlich seine eigene String-Implementierung,
weil die Standard-String halt einfach
absoluter Rotz ist, Alter.
In Chat-PS4 läuft praktisch gar nichts.
Das ist bei Early-Emulators immer noch so.
Aha.
String-Stelz.
Aber viel mehr als Standard-String kann das auch nicht, oder?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Aber das sieht halbwegs ordentlich aus.
Okay, Logging.
Logging ist immer ordentlich.
Formatter.
Textformatter CPP.
Guck mal, selbst ordentliches
C++ sieht hässlich as fuck aus.
Und das ist noch hübsches.
Das ist noch hübsches C++.
Also, der hat sich richtig Mühe gegeben.
Das hier geht jetzt.
Das sieht echt ganz schön aus.
Das ist okay.
Aber C++ sieht halt immer eklig aus.
Kannst du machen, was du willst.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, Rust sieht auch teilweise richtig eklig aus.
Nicht, dass Rust jetzt die schönste Sprache ist.
So was hier schon sieht wie Static, Cast, Class.
Ah, C++, MonkaS, Alter.
Und das ist aber wie gesagt, das ist noch schönes C++.
Okay, das trendet.
Aber immerhin.
Ein interessantes Projekt, was nicht AI ist.
So, was trendet denn diese Woche in...
Haben wir mal geguckt, was in Deutschland trendet?
Da trendet, glaube ich, gar nichts, ne?
Genau.
Das geht nämlich gar nicht.
Okay, was trendet in Aserbaidschan?
Auch nichts.
Eigentlich könnte man diese Sache komplett...
Okay, französisch.
Französisch.
French.
Die beschreiben doch...
Auch nett.
Ja, okay, da könnte...
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dieser Filter ist einfach kaputt.
und die haben nicht hart genug
gevibe-coded bei GitHub,
um den zu entfernen.
Okay, Language. Was trendet denn in Go
diese Woche?
China. China können wir tatsächlich
mal gucken. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das sollte
Chinese.
Okay, da trendet tatsächlich ein bisschen was.
Die China-Chinesen
sind am Start. Gut.
Dann gucken wir mal, was in Go trendet.
irgendwas Spannendes.
Äh, AI.
Keine Ahnung was,
aber wahrscheinlich
äh, ne. Was ist das?
Highly opinionated
MTP.
Protoproxy.
Men
tinde pittel.
Was? Keine Ahnung,
was eine MTProtoproxy
ist.
Es ist zumindest nicht AI.
Open Source Cloud Native Distributed SQL Database.
Uiuiuiui.
Wow, es ist auch mal nicht KI, was trendet.
Ne, im Prinzip schreibt die ganze Welt einfach, also gerade auf GitHub, das ist alles in Englisch.
Außer die China-Chinesen.
Wahrscheinlich auch die Nordkoreaner oder so, keine Ahnung.
Aber es gibt ein paar Länder, die machen das halt gerne in ihrer eigenen Sprache.
Deswegen hat mich auch gewundert, dass nix auf French trendet.
Die Franzosen machen das ja auch ganz gerne.
Aber anscheinend nicht genug.
Aber die ganze Welt schreibt eigentlich auf Englisch.
Anscheinend außer die Chinesen.
Und die Nordkoreaner haben bestimmt ihr eigenes GitHub.
Kim Hub oder irgendwie sowas.
Okay, das ist schon mal
Vibe-Coded.
Ist...
Ist das eine Datenbank, die Vibe-Coded ist?
Da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht so großes Vertrauen in eine Datenbank,
die Vibe-Coded ist.
Ist sie denn wirklich gevibecoded?
Wie alt ist denn das Projekt?
Also ich sehe hier keine Comets von Claude oder sonst was.
Also wahrscheinlich ist sie nicht vibecoded.
Übrigens wisst ihr was, was ich richtig eklig finde?
Dass man bei GitHub nicht einfach, oder vielleicht bin ich einfach nur zu dumm, Leute.
Gibt es bei GitHub keine Möglichkeit, das glaube ich gab es aber auch noch nie,
einfach das erste Comet mir anzuzeigen, ohne dieses dumme Gescrolle hier zu machen.
Ich meine, ich kann hier jetzt 99999 oder so reinschreiben.
Dann bin ich auf Seite sonst was.
Aber das kann es doch nicht sein, oder?
Schreiben wir hier mal 50.000 hin oder so?
Da, no commits, ja.
Also keine Ahnung.
Das ist halt wieder richtig, richtig lächerlich.
Also ich glaube nicht wirklich, dass das wipecoded ist.
Vielleicht teilweise.
Ah, guck mal hier.
Plants, MD.
Naja.
Zumindest ist das mal ein halbwegs interessantes Projekt.
Distributed Databases.
Was fällt mir da?
Cassandra DB gab es mal mit.
Oder hieß das nicht so?
Distributed Database.
Okay.
Habe ich keinen Anwendungszweck für, aber immerhin mal ein interessantes Projekt, was nicht KI ist.
So, was haben wir sonst noch? AI.
Go FR.
Opinionated Golang Framework
for Accelerated Microservice Development.
Accelerate
ist auch so ein Buzzword aktuell.
Das was accelerated wird.
Aha.
Und was genau
macht es?
Simplify Microservice Development.
Kubernetes Deployment.
Auch noch die Box Observability.
Ja, zeigt mir Bilder irgendwie.
Warum, was, wie.
Das ist, das ist, das ist einfach ein Web,
Backend Framework oder?
Ich check's jetzt ehrlich gesagt
noch nicht so ganz.
Weil ich seh jetzt ja auch nicht
den Vorteil davon, in Hello World
Get Requests machen zu können.
Also was kann das?
Quickstart.
Hello Server.
Vielleicht haben die...
Ich find da so Sachen immer ganz spannend.
Accelerated Microservice.
Könnt ihr das nicht mal irgendwie schreiben?
Was ist hier an Accelerated? Das sieht in der Standard-Library
fast genauso aus.
Warum ist das jetzt Accelerated?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Es gibt auch keine...
Getting Started. Okay.
Opinionated Web Framework.
Schreib das doch gleich dahin, da weiß man wenigstens, was man sieht.
Ein Opinionated Web Framework.
Okay, da kann ich mir wenigstens was darunter vorstellen.
Robust Scalable Applications.
Ja gut.
Für größere Web-Anwendungen vielleicht ganz gut.
Das ist halt das Ding, wo man sich fragt,
ist das dann in einem halben Jahr noch supported?
Steht bei GitHub direkt rechts oben?
Nee, da steht Accelerated irgendwas.
Nee, guck, steht nicht.
Da steht nicht Webframe,
da steht nur Opinionated Golang Framework.
Wenn da Webframework gestanden hätte,
hätte ich es besser verstanden.
Warte.
Okay, die Webseite ist schon mal irgendwie
ein wenig kaputt.
Und in Memory
Pupsup? Weil ich will jetzt nicht
mal random
Kafka aufsetzen.
Okay, whatever. Juckt mich auch nicht.
Werde ich wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit nicht verwenden.
Okay.
Ähm
AI
Fast Reverse, das kennen wir schon
DOLT
Git for Data
DOLT ist SQL Database
Oh
Aha
Ah
Okay, das ist KI-Build
Also
Eine SQL Datenbank ohne SQL
Oder, hä?
Also das check ich nicht so ganz, aber
Ey, coole Sache
Keine Ahnung wann und warum und weshalb
Aber immerhin
Auch mal ein interessantes Projekt
Was nicht KI ist
Next Generation Crawling and Spidering
Framework
Wahrscheinlich für KI
Da wird, da wird gecrawled.
An open source AI integrated cross platform terminal.
Oh Gott.
Jetzt haben wir schon KI-Terminals.
Gut, das ist ja nicht das erste.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich.
West Herm, beste.
und etcd trendet okay so dann gucken wir noch mal was in was was trendet denn in
dotnet aktuell so bestimmt nichts spannendes das übliche das übliche das
übliche windows stells unity ai powershell
Äh
Github Runner
GUI Client for Git Users
GUI Clients for Git sind
Schrott
Kommandozeile einzig wahre
No Kappa
Ich mein das ernst
IDE Plugins
Git GUIs kannst du alles vergessen
Avalonia Trended, okay das hat's auf jeden Fall verdient
Avalonia ist POG
Leider
leider ist das so ekliges
XML für das Gui. Ich mag das
einfach nicht.
Die Kekomrits sind am Start.
Bei DPI Manager.
Moment.
Wir können das Emoji so selten verwenden.
Wo haben wir es denn?
Hier, da ist er.
Ich hoffe, das ist russisch.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es auch irgendwas anderes.
Welche Sprache ist das?
Okay, was...
Was genau macht das jetzt?
Ist das irgendwie, um irgendwelche Sperren in Russland zu umgehen oder was?
Mini-Utility-Freunding bei DP...
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Proxyfry.
Wozu und warum und wann
Und keine Ahnung
Humanizer
Das ist auch eine gute Library
Okay, und das letzte, was trendet
Das muss sein
Geht ja nicht anders
Nein, Leute, C++
Damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet, oder?
Jetzt hab ich euch gebetet
was trennt bei c++
der ps4 atmosphere work in progress customized film war für nintendo switch aha
Java, Wasim Runtime, Cloudfly Workers, Lama, CPP.
Leute, ich sag's nur nochmal, ich zitter nicht, ne?
Das ist, die Maus buggt manchmal, beziehungsweise diese Maus-Sharing-Software buggt manchmal rum und dann wackelt hier der Cursor.
So.
Dann irgendwelche
AI-Gesch...
Array
Framework for Apple Silicon. Okay, keine Ahnung,
Ist das dieses KI-Model-Format für Apple oder ist das was anderes?
Playstation 2 Emulator.
C++ ist so advanced und high IQ, oder so wir, je nachdem wie man es will,
dass wenn ich die Projektbeschreibung lese, kaum verstehe, um was es überhaupt geht.
Main Ton Monorepo, aha.
Okay, TensorFlow kenne ich, Elektron kennen wir mittlerweile alle.
Ich finde es interessant, dass Elektron weniger Sterne hat als beispielsweise OpenClaw.
Aber OpenClaw ist ja eh durch die Decke.
XLA, Machine Learning Compiler, GPU, CPU, Dolphin.
Das ist ein Gamecube-Emulator.
Rotowarf, OpenTDD.
Open Source Simulation Game
Based on Transport Tycoon Deluxe.
Okay.
Gibt keine Screenshots.
Outdated, overrated.
Telegram Desktop.
SPD Log.
Das habe ich mal benutzt.
Das kenne ich.
Das ist eine Logging Library,
die FMT-Lib verwendet.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf...
Das ist eigentlich ganz okay.
OCR.
Anti-Detect-Browser.
Was darf ich mir darunter vorstellen?
Camufox.
Oder Camufox.
Web-Scraper.
Ah, ein Web-Scraper, der nicht als Scraper erkannt werden soll.
Wollen wir was schauen?
Wie viele Sterne OpenClaw hat?
Ich glaube 350.000 oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, 330.000.
Esoterik-Software.
Was ist das? Moment, lass mich mal kurz checken.
It's over.
Ah.
Internet-Shutdown
Naja, das wollen wir nicht gucken
Zu viel Realität
Kein Bock auf Realität
So, okay
Dann gucken wir als letztes jetzt noch
Weil ich da immer gerne
Was rendet denn bei den Blazingly Fast
Ritten in Rust Krustentiere
Hast du mitbekommen, dass
Nvidia jetzt einen Fork von OpenClaw gebaut hat
NemoClaw, ne, hab ich nicht
Ist das auf GitHub?
Ich habe gehört, dass es irgendwie einen Trick gibt
Ich kann das aber weder bestätigen
noch habe ich es ausprobiert
Ich habe gehört, es gibt einen Trick
Es gibt wohl irgendwie so ein
Nvidia Developer Programm oder sowas
wo man kostenlos Zugriff
auf ganz viele KI Models bekommen kann
mit wohl einem sehr großzügigen
Free Tier
Hab ich gehört
Keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt
Okay, natürlich ist Claude dabei
Was sonst?
OpenClaude more secure
Ist nicht gerade der Witz bei OpenClaude
Dass man auf Security komplett scheißt
Dachte, das wäre da
Teil des Reizes
OpenClaude zu verwenden
Blazingly fast
Terminal File Manager
Written in Rust. Das hat die Welt gebraucht, Leute.
Ein Terminal File Manager, blazingly fast, written in Rust.
KI, ey, KI, read me, hör.
Okay, so sieht's also aus.
Aha.
Jetzt hab ich mal ne ernst gemeinte Frage an euch, Chat.
Wozu braucht man einen Terminal File Manager,
wenn man doch CP und MV und LESS und sowas hat?
was ist der vorteil von einem oder wim zum öffnen was ist der vorteil von einem
terminal file manager das verstehe ich nicht außer dass er ritten in russ ist
also nichts davon was ich hier sehe würde ich gerne über irgend so ein tui
interface machen anstelle von mv zum beispiel preview preview habe ich auch
mit mit meinem terminal auf bilder zum beispiel ja also wenn man jetzt hier
hingeht habe ich ein bilder freund ich habe noch kein bild ja ja ja gif copy
link wie geht's
image cat
Also ich kann auch Bilder anzeigen lassen im Terminal, ohne Terminal File Manager.
So.
Also das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich habe das früher aber auch schon nicht verstanden.
Es gab ja früher, wie hieß das Ding? Ranger?
Ist das Ranger?
Ich glaube Ranger hieß das, dieser CLI-Filemanager.
Ich habe auch nie verstanden, was da dran so toll ist.
Ist doch zu anstrengend, dauernd befehlt.
Du tippst doch hier auch laufend auf der Tastatur in einem Terminal File Manager.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich schneller und einfacher ist.
Außerdem gewöhnst du dich dann da dran und wenn du dich demnächst mal per SSH auf den Server einloggst, hast du die Helfe vergessen.
Ne, also ich sehe da keinen Sinn drin.
Genauso wenig wie ich Sinn drin sehe, irgendwelche Git-UIs, GUIs zu haben oder IDE-Plugins.
Braucht man nicht.
Das hatten wir eben schon.
VEED Plus.
Ah, das ist, das ist, das ist, ähm...
Das kann man sich zusätzlich lizenzieren für VEED, ne?
Das hab ich, da hab ich mal irgendeinen, äh, einen...
Einen Talk gesehen von dem VEED-Gründer.
Erfinder.
Vue.js und VEED-Erfinder.
Emax kann alles.
Wie war das so?
Emax kann alles und guter Editor wäre nicht schlecht noch.
Das ist jetzt kostenlos und open. Aha.
Also es gibt ein paar Sachen, die mir einfallen, die Emax nicht gut kann.
Vielleicht mittlerweile, aber als ich zuletzt Emax verwendet habe, konnte das Emax nicht.
Das erste ist ein gescheiter Browser in Emax.
den, den man wirklich benutzen kann.
Ich weiß, macht keinen Sinn, ist aber ein Ding, wenn man sagt, alles kann in Emacs gemacht werden, dann das nicht.
Und das nächste ist Emojis.
Emojis gingen nicht damals, als ich Emacs verwendet habe.
Das einzige, was Emacs damals konnte, war so ein Emoji-Plugin, das Emoji-Unicode durch Bilder-Overlays in Emacs ersetzt hat.
Aber das war ganz eklig, das konntest du ja nicht richtig copy-pasten und das hat rumgebuckt und das war ganz eklig.
Und dann kam irgendjemand mal auf die Idee und hat Emoji-Support gepatcht für Emacs auf Mac.
Daraufhin kam einer der Emacs-Leute
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Mr. Emacs himself gewesen ist
Und hat gesagt
Er wirft das wieder raus aus Emacs
Weil es ist nicht Cross-Plattform, es ist Mac-Only
Deswegen kriegt keiner Emojis
Und daraufhin habe ich mir gedacht
Ey, keine Ahnung
macht eigentlich gar keinen Sinn,
sich weiter damit zu beschäftigen.
Und seitdem habe ich nie mehr Emacs verwendet.
Ich habe nie Emacs großartig
als Haupteditor verwendet.
Aber so ab und zu habe ich mich immer mal
ein bisschen mit Ork-Mode beschäftigt und sowas.
Aber daraufhin habe ich gedacht, ey,
Emacs wird nie ein richtig moderner Editor mehr sein.
Aber gut, das hat sich ja vielleicht geändert.
Orch-Code.
AI-enabled
pair-pro... Okay, KI.
UV-Python-Stells.
Making your shell
magical. Das ist auch
wieder eine Projektbeschreibung, wo du keine Ahnung hast.
Ach, ist das das mit der Schildkröte?
Das kenne ich, glaube ich. Wenn das das mit der
Schildkröte ist, dann kenne ich das.
Das ist das mit der Schildkröte.
Okay, ja.
Magical Shell History.
Ja, okay, das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Habe ich, glaube ich, sogar mal ausprobiert und festgestellt,
Brauch ich nicht.
Codex.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass das written in Rust ist.
Deno?
Sally J?
Das hab ich auch mal ausprobiert.
Hab ich auch den Reiz daran nicht verstanden.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Temux, nur noch viel übertriebener.
So mit Maus-Support und ganz abgedrehtem Zeug.
Ich bleib bei Temux.
Auf Servern. Lokal nicht. Lokal hab ich
Westterm. Das macht alles, was
Temux sonst auch machen würde.
Und mir lokal
Rolldown, Bundler,
Coco in AI.
AI.
Westterm!
Das hat's verdient. Westterm ist
pog. Gibt's eigentlich mal wieder ein neues
Release mittlerweile? Ich habe irgendeinen
Beta-Release. Oh, fuck. Von 2024
ist das letzte Release.
Warum ist das letzte Release eigentlich so alt?
Da tut sich doch fast...
Tut sich doch laufen was.
Naja, laufen. Das ist jetzt zwei Monate her, aber
könnte mal ein neues Release geben.
Hat man überhaupt eine Chance auf viele Sterne
auf GitHub, wenn das Projekt nicht in Rust geschrieben ist?
Ja, klar. Hast du?
Ähm.
Ich meine sogar der Fiat Champ hat über 100 Sterne.
Und alles Anwendungsfehler.
Blockchain Pimp.
Okay, es waren ja tatsächlich mal ein paar ganz interessante Projekte heute dabei.
Muss man ja mal sagen.
Ein paar ganz spannende Projekte am Start.
Oh, neue Updates. Wir haben doch erst vor einer Viertelstunde geupdatet.
Ein paar ganz spannende Projekte, die nicht KI waren.
Das hat es doch heute mal gelohnt.
Ich glaube, das machen wir jetzt immer so.
Wir gucken das in der Reihenfolge durch.
Daily, Weekly, Go, C-Sharp, Rust.
Nicht unbedingt C++.
Oh, guck mal, jetzt haben wir Kernel-Updates.
Jetzt muss ich rebooten.
Endlich.
Hab schon drauf gewartet.
By the way, warum?
Warum?
Ich hab gar kein Kernel-Update.
Warum muss ich jetzt genau rebooten?
Wegen BTFS-Prox vielleicht?
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, warum ich jetzt genau Kernelgedöns in der TrumpFS neu generiert habe?
Ja, wahrscheinlich wegen BTFS-Prox.
Okay, Leute.
Reboot.
Warum ist Rolldown nur als fast beschrieben?
Moment, war das written in Rust?
Dann ist das eindeutig falsch.
Dann muss es blazingly fast sein.
nutzt du cashios jetzt als main os ja also als main linux os ja
Also ich benutze hier Windows
Und hier Linux
Guck da
Das ist keine VM
Das ist ein Mini-PC mittlerweile
Na Gaming ist auf dem Mini-PC jetzt nicht wirklich
Also das hier ist
Also hier, Windows habe ich nach wie vor
Auf meiner
Fetten Gaming Kiste
Mit
Wie viel Kerne hat das Teil
Das ist total abgedreht
Mit 24 Kernen
Der Rechner ist 3 Jahre alt
Naja, nicht
Ne Moment
Der Rechner ist über 3 Jahre alt schon
Krass oder
Leute, das ist so heftig
Wie wenig sich Hardware mäßig tut
Oder
guck mal, das ist ein Rechner
von Ende
und der ist immer noch
High End
das ist
die CPU ist immer noch sauschnell
vielleicht nicht High End, aber immer noch
ganz obere
Oberklasse, ja
das ist
die CPU ist immer noch
brutal schnell
und eine 4090
ist immer noch eines der besten
und schnellsten Grafikkarten,
die es gibt. Also überlegt euch
mal, überlegt euch mal ernsthaft.
Der Rechner
wird dieses Jahr, Ende dieses Jahres
wird der Rechner,
drei Jahre alt, überlegt mal, drei Jahre alter
Rechner war damals
top, top, top high-end
und ist jetzt nur noch high-end.
Wann gab es das denn zuletzt, Alter?
Wenn ich
daran zurückdenke
Wenn du dir 1998
einen Rechner gekauft hast
Ja, oder, oder, ja, du hast dir 1998
einen Rechner gekauft, den konntest du
Den konntest du nach eineinhalb Jahren
fast wegschmeißen, weil er nächstes Mal drauf lief
Und jetzt hast du einen High-End Rechner
Der ist nach drei Jahren immer noch High-End
WTF
Also das hier ist
Also das hier ist mein Gaming Rechner
Mit dem
13900K und der 4090
Der RTX 4090
Und
Das hier ist ein Linux Mini PC
Mit nem Ryzen
HS
Beste Abkürzung immer noch für ne CPU
und einer integrierten Grafikkarte.
Aber halt alles AMD,
weil das für Linux auch besser ist.
Ja. Also ich hab zwei Sachen
jetzt am Schal. Mini-PC, der steht tatsächlich
ganz klein, das ist hier so ein
so ein Mini-PC ist das.
Ein Teil hier.
Also der ist wirklich klein und leicht.
Der steht oben drauf auf meinem
Gaming-PC.
Und ich kann jetzt halt einfach
dazwischen switchen. Guck, hier
Windows Gaming PC, was ich benutzen kann
für Streaming, Gaming,
Videos, Thumbnails, Videos schneiden,
wenn ich ja Videos machen würde.
Und hier habe ich meine Linux-Kiste
mit allem, was man so braucht und Cache-US.
Ich finde, für mich ist das
das optimale Setup.
Linux und Windows einfach parallel.
Und hier nebendran,
so was ihr jetzt hier nicht seht,
hier auf der linken Seite vom Bildschirm
steht ein zweiter Bildschirm, das ist Streaming-Vorschau-Rechner
und sowas.
Den du hast, wird von dem neuen Core einfach umrundet.
Warum?
Weil der mehr Kerne hat?
Oder weil die Kerne so viel besser geworden sind?
Aber umrundet kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein aktueller Prozessor quasi in dieser Leistungskategorie wie damals der 13900K doppelt so schnell ist.
Es sei denn, er hat doppelt so viele Kerne.
Okay.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Was ist denn aktuell?
I9?
14?
Ne, was ist denn?
Was ist der neueste I9 Prozessor?
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn der schnellste I9?
Ja
Oder soll ich mal mit AMD vergleichen
Das Ding hier oder was
Okay, nehmen wir mal
14.900k, das scheint ja der aktuelle zu sein
Was, Core
2,9, was
Okay
Das ist der neue, der ist von 2014
Wie jetzt?
8?
Das da
Von wann ist der?
Steht das irgendwo da?
Okay, Ende 2024
Okay, whatever
Äh, versus 13.900k
Das ist übrigens fake, ne?
33 Nanometer, da ist nix 3 Nanometer
Naja, also, jetzt mal ernsthaft, Leute
Der umrundet doch meine CPU nicht
Der ist 10% schneller
Und das nach 3 Jahren
Jetzt mach doch mal halblang
Mit der umrundet meine CPU
10-13% schneller würde ich jetzt nicht überrunden nennen
Wollen wir es mal mit AMD vergleichen?
Auch wenn es vielleicht nicht so ein ganz fairer Vergleich ist
Und selbst Single Core hat es da nicht wirklich
Okay, was haben wir noch
9950X3D
Wie viel kostet das Ding
Okay, auch geht
Okay, Versus 13.900k
Wie viel, erst einmal will ich mal vorher was gucken
Wie viel Kerne und alles hat denn dieses Ding hier
Zeig mal her
Okay
16 Kerne
32, okay, da hat meiner sogar noch
ein bisschen mehr Kerne, aber der hat wahrscheinlich
echte 16 Kerne und nicht diese
Efficiency Performance Score Geschichte, oder?
Na gut, gucken wir mal
Versus
13.900k
Da ist ja noch weniger Unterschied.
Chat, da ist ja nur 7% Unterschied.
Ja, jetzt sag doch mal, der macht, der überrundet meine CPU.
Die Webseite ist pepega.
Okay, welche ist denn besser?
Die hier.
Ich sehe da aber jetzt auch nicht so viel Unterschied, ehrlich gesagt
Guck mal, hier ist sogar
Angeblich meiner schneller
Aber Single Core müssen wir mal gucken
Single Core
Oh, guck mal, die CPU hat einen Punkt mehr Single Core
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung
Wo soll ich das sonst noch vergleichen hier?
Was sind Preise?
Okay, hier ist er
Hier ist er 20
Hier ist er 20%, immerhin, immerhin
Immerhin
Ja gut, Stromverbrauch, keck, wait, Alter
Okay, hier ist er zumindest ein bisschen schneller
Aber umrunden ist das immer noch nicht.
Gut.
Hätten wir das auch geklärt.
Hier nochmal.
17%.
Ja, ich glaube ja.
Leute, es wäre ja auch eher ein Witz, wenn sich in drei Jahren gar nichts getan hätte.
Aber 17%, das ist ja weit weg von umrunden.
Das ist immer noch eines der schnellsten CPUs überhaupt.
Und das nach drei Jahren.
Und das Beste ist, die ist ja auch noch wassergekühlt.
Das heißt, der taktet sich auch nicht irgendwie großartig runter oder so.
Also das ist wirklich krass.
Nach drei Jahren High-End-Rechner immer noch High-End-Rechner.
Moin.
Hast du halt noch gut eingekauft
vor dem AI-Shit. Das wohl war.
Wobei, ich muss sagen,
ganz ehrlich, so gut
eingekauft
hab ich nicht,
weil,
wenn man sich das mal anguckt,
ja,
das ist überhaupt nicht meine festplatte okay was auch immer wenn man sich das mal anguckt ja
die ssd hatte firma probleme bei release dass die wie heißt das dass dieses das
will er fliegen also quasi dieses verteilen von schreibzyklen und sowas und ich richtig
funktioniert hat in dem entsprechen hat sich die ssd viel schneller abgenutzt muss das der
firmware update machen also eines der kernkomponenten vom pc schon mal
verbuggt ssd nächste intel 3 13.900 k hatte probleme mit irgendwie ich weiß es
gar nicht mehr was was waren das noch mal für probleme mit den intel cpu die
hatten irgendwie zu viel spannung und und und die cpu sagt irgendwie ach ich
weiß nicht mehr zumindest haben sich die cpu ist auch der hat genau die die cpu
hat sich intern selbst ersetzt so mit der zeit also cpu auch grober großer
fehler ja nächstes ram habe ich mir gekauft
guck mal was der scheiß mittlerweile kostet man der ram war damals schon
unsinnig teuer. So,
RAM mit 6400, also quasi
Overclocking RAM
gekauft. Was ist?
Der RAM schafft es nicht.
Overclocking,
mit dem Takt gibt es ab und zu random
Blue Screens. Wenn ich sie einfach
runtersetze auf normalen,
auf normalen Takt, also was ist normaler Takt?
5400 oder sowas? Keine Probleme.
Also, auch im Arsch.
So, nächste. Grafikkarte. Kommt
abfackeln am Stecker.
Also, seht mal, die vier zentralsten Komponenten in dem Rechner hatten alle große Probleme.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen, was das für eine scheiß Hardwarequalität war.
Grafikkarte kann abfackeln, RAM packt den aufgedruckten Takt nicht, CPU zersetzt sich intern selbst, SSD zersetzt sich intern selbst.
Ja, das Mainboard ist gut, das Funst.
Ähm, der Thermal Crystalline Contact Frame ist gut.
Oh, da hätte ich heute auch ein Problem.
Wir haben doch letztens das Video vom Bauer geguckt, dass er kein Alu und Kupfer mehr bekommt.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es diese Dinger jetzt mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
Weil sie die nicht mehr fräsen können.
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich gar nicht genau, warum ich überhaupt einen CPU-Contact-Frame habe.
Chet, das wisst ihr besser als ich.
Warum habe ich einen CPU-Contact-Frame?
Was ist der Sinn davon?
Ich glaube, der Sinn war, dass die Oberfläche von der CPU, dass es besser quasi gerade drauf gedrückt ist, sodass der Kühler planer drauf sitzt.
Also auch wirklich so im Unter-Millimeter-Bereich, ja.
So im Mikrometer-Bereich.
Und es deswegen besser kühlt.
Ist das nicht das Problem gewesen?
Ne, ich hab da nichts geköpft bei der CPU.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich ein Contact Frame habe.
Ich habe damals anscheinend gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
So, das Gehäuse ist mega pock.
Das ist riesig groß, das Gehäuse, Leute.
Das ist wirklich das fetteste Gehäuse, was ich jemals hatte.
Guckt euch das mal an.
XL.
Guck mal hier
Seht ihr wie groß das Gehäuse ist
Das ist riesig
Guck mal das ist riesig das Gehäuse
Und oben habe ich halt die Wasserkühlung drin
Aber das Gehäuse ist gut
Das Ding, Wasserkühlung
funktioniert auch gut und das Netzteil funktioniert auch gut
Aber schon heftig, oder? Wie schlecht die Hardware-Qualität ist
Die vier fast zentralsten
Komponenten neben dem Mainboard
hatten alle
Defekte
Oder Designmängel, sagen wir mal
Nicht Defekte, aber
Das ist schon ganz schöner Mist
Oh, ich hab
hätte Rino nicht gestartet.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, ob ich alles hier...
Sieht aus wie ein Server. Ja, das ist riesig.
Das ist richtig fett.
Das RAM-Problem liegt
vermutlich auch nur an der CPU.
Das hat er von Anfang an gehabt. Das kann nicht an der CPU
liegen, dass die abgenutzt ist oder so.
Das hat er von Anfang an gehabt.
Und die war bestimmt nicht von Anfang an
abgenutzt. Und wenn die
abgenutzt wäre, hätte er mit 5400
auch Blue Screens.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es an der CPU liegt.
Ja, und der RAM ist einfach
zu hohem Takt
verkauft worden.
Weil der Anpressdruck des normalen
Mount-Mechanismus Murks ist.
Aha.
Siehste?
Also,
das sagt ja.
Also anscheinend war das eine gute Idee, mir den Contact-Frame zu holen.
Chat.
Meine 5070 bringt mein System immer zum Abschmieren.
Bildschirm wird schwarz und danach paar Sekunden rebooted Windows.
Soweit ich das rausgelesen habe, soll das was mit den Wiedertreibern zu tun haben.
Hat jemand eine Idee? Neue Treiber?
Das klingt für mich...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Treiberproblem ist.
Ich habe mich damit...
Also, letzter Zeit keine Ahnung.
Aber komplett abschmieren und rebooten...
klingt jetzt nicht unbedingt nach hardware probleme nach nach treiber problem wohl eher
nach hardware problem keine ahnung also ist im leerlauf du hast du den stream offen das
Ding, dann hat das Ding irgendeinen Schaden.
Dann hat das Ding irgendeinen Schlag.
Ist mein Bauchgefühl.
Ich hab, äh,
wissen kann ich natürlich nicht, ja.
Beim Gamen passiert es nicht.
Okay, das ist, das ist merkwürdig.
Dann ist es vielleicht doch irgendeine Treibergeschichte?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wackelkontakt hab ich auch grad dran gedacht
Wackelkontakt in irgendeiner Art und Weise vielleicht
Aber dann müsste es ja beim Game
Früher oder später auch vorkommen
Vielleicht sitzt du ruhiger vorm Rechner
Wenn du am Spiel bist
Ne, ich hab
Dann hab ich keine Ahnung
So
Gut
dann
nochmal kurz eine Runde Ascii
Quarium entspannen. Ich trinke mal meinen Tee.
Ah!
Excellent!
Ich meine mal mit Linux booten,
mit einer Linux Live CD booten,
dass man immer noch Live CD sagt, ist auch hängen geblieben
eigentlich, oder? Mit einem Live Linux
Da kann ein Hai-Angriff kommen, ja, ja.
Guck hier, warte mal, ich spule mal vor und dann siehst du den Hai.
Der Hai, der kommt dann auch irgendwann gleich noch.
Pass auf, wo kommt der Hai?
Hai-Stelz, wo ist der Hai?
Chat, wo ist der Hai?
Normalerweise gibt es da auch einen Hai.
Wo ist der denn?
Wo ist der Hai? Da! Guck! Bam! Und jetzt hat der Hai den Fisch gefressen.
Der Hai hat sonntags frei.
Okay.
So, dann gehen wir mal rüber.
Schauen wir uns mal an, was können wir uns denn heute hier angucken auf YouTube.
Moment, Musik hatten wir schon.
Was ist das denn?
70, gucken wir mal, was auf YouTube empfohlen wird.
Oh, das gucke ich immer gerne.
Why a Raspberry Pi can't be a stoplight.
Eigentlich vollkommen wurscht.
Ähm.
Ach, Moment, ich dachte, es gibt einen Best-of, Steve Ballmer flippt aus auf der Bühne.
Moment, Moment, was zum Teufel?
Installing Art-Schniedungs-SFM-Boy every day.
Okay, was auch immer.
Must have services.
Okay, das gucke ich auch immer so gerne.
Später gespeichert.
Ja, es verrat mich alles.
Production ready.
Hier ist das Internet.
Der wichtigste Ort im Internet, den kaum jemand kennt.
Okay.
Da haben wir ja ein paar Videos, die wir gucken können.
Erstmal schöner Generator am Start.
Na dann.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns aber erst einmal an, was der hier sagt.
Das geht nämlich nur 9 Minuten und ihr wisst, ich werde immer schnell sidetracked.
Wurde mir vorhin empfohlen.
Mal gucken.
Also 70 Tage Linux.
Ich gehe nicht mehr zurück.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Vielleicht taugt das Video auch nichts.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Komm mal, der befindet CacheOS.
Er ist Arch, by the way.
Er entwickelt Jetbrains,
benutzt einen Rider Avalonia.
Wo stellst du... Ah, das ist ja interessant.
Ein .NET-Entwickler.
Also ein
hauptberuflicher .NET
Professional .NET-Entwickler, der auf
Linux ist. Das finde ich cool.
Ihr wisst, ich benutze auch seit Jahren schon .NET
und bin seit Jahren fürs Entwickeln auch nur auf Linux.
Aber ich bin ja kein hauptberuflicher .NET-Entwickler.
Das finde ich interessant, dass es
da auch Leute gibt, die das wohl professionell
einsetzen. Ich meine, warum auch nicht?
Hören wir uns das mal an, was er zu sagen hat.
Vor 70 Tagen habe ich Windows den Rücken gekehrt.
Mein Ziel, volle Kontrolle über meine Hardware, ohne dass meine Produktivität als Entwickler und Content Creator einbricht.
Ich wollte wissen, kann ein Arch-basiertes System wie CacheOS meinen professionellen Alltag stemmen?
In den letzten zwei Monaten habe ich alles gemacht.
Programmieren, Livekurse, Recording, Videoschnitt und und und.
Und heute ziehen wir Bilanz.
Ich erzähle euch, warum mein mühsam aufgebautes Windows-Sicherheitsnetz zur Zeitfalle wurde,
wie mich ein technischer Totalausfall zum Eingreifen gezwungen hat und warum ich heute trotzdem kein...
Bei Internetentwicklern ist Mac und Linux sehr beliebt.
Ist ja auch verständlich, weil Windows sagt...
...Schweißperlen mehr auf der Stirn habe, wenn ich den PC einschalte.
Kein Schönreden, einfach nur der nackte Workflow-Check nach 70 Tagen.
Erinnert euch an meine erste Anforderung. Ich wollte im Prinzip alles, was Windows kann, nur eben besser.
Mehr Privatsphäre, mehr Speed und vor allem deutlich mehr Kontrolle.
Und was soll ich sagen? CacheOS hat geliefert.
Tatsächlich kann mein System heute mehr als mein altes Windows-Setup.
Das System ist irrsinnig schnell, zum Beispiel der WG Resolve, dreistündiges Video gerendert.
Das System bleibt stabil und performant, ohne dass irgendwas nicht geht.
Wir können das wirklich ein bisschen schneller machen, ne?
Kontrolle, Autop, wie in Dolphin zusätzliche Buttons für meinen Workflow brauche oder Widgets auf meinem Touch-Display anpasse.
Das funktioniert einfach.
Hardware-Support, Stift-Input, Touch-Display.
Genau, das ist genau der richtige Speed.
Capture Card läuft alles reibungslos.
Komplexere Sachen wie KI-Modelle oder RDP-Verbindungen
funktionieren auch einfach.
Einen kleinen Dämpfer gibt es aber trotzdem, den muss ich euch sagen.
Ganz selten macht nämlich meine
Dockingstation Probleme. Die wird nicht mehr erkannt.
Dann muss ich sie kurz vom Strom abstecken.
Das kenne ich zwar auch von Windows.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das habe ich mit meinem Arbeits-
Notebook auch.
Und das ist Windows.
Wenn ich
meinen Bildschirm sperre und der geht dann irgendwann
in Stand-by,
weil ich was essen bin oder so, und ich komme
dann wieder, dann entsperre ich das Notebook.
Der Bildschirm am Notebook geht an,
aber der Bildschirm, der quasi
angeschlossen ist am Notebook, der geht
dann nicht an. Da muss ich erst abstöpseln,
wieder neu dranstöpseln, dann geht's.
Aber Perfektion ist das nicht. Deshalb gibt's
von mir da einen Punkt Abzug.
Der Score für diesen Punkt, 9 von 10 Punkten.
Und jetzt wird's kurz schmerzhaft.
Meine zweite Anforderung war ja die sogenannte
Existenzsicherung, meine 10-Minuten-Regel.
Falls Linux im Ernstfall Probleme macht,
wollte ich innerhalb von 10 Minuten auf mein
Windows-System wechseln können und direkt weiterarbeiten.
Siehste? Siehste?
Deswegen, deswegen
einfach so ein Setup wie ich hab,
ich hab ne Windows-Kiste
und ne Linux-Kiste.
Und das funktioniert wunderbar.
Und ich hab immer irgendwie was ready.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
das ist das beste Setup, was es gibt.
Also für mich.
Das heißt nicht, dass es für jeden das beste
Setup sein muss. Windows hier,
Linux da. Achso, und weil irgendjemand
Chat, hatte nicht vorhin jemand gefragt,
wie ich umschalte zwischen Windows und Linux?
Soll ich das nochmal kurz zeigen?
Ihr wisst, ich zeig das gerne. Ich hab damit
keine Schmerzen, das zu zeigen.
Soll ich das nochmal zeigen? Pausechamp.
Pausechamp. Pausechamp.
Okay, ihr habt gelitten. Ich zeig das jetzt einfach nochmal.
Also.
So.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ich zeig's.
Also, auf der Windows-Kiste hier habe ich zwei Desktops.
Desktop 1, Desktop 2.
Desktop 1 ist ganz normal, das was ihr hier seht.
Und Desktop 2 ist Linux im Fullscreen.
Fragt man sich, wie das geht.
Funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ich schalte jetzt mal nur zwischen, guck hier Desktop 1, Desktop 2, zwischen den Desktop mit Maus und Tastatur um.
Ich habe hier einen OBS laufen im Fullscreen und das OBS capturt über eine Elgato Capture Card mit 240 Hertz mein Linux Mini PC Output und ich habe quasi nur hier das OBS im Fullscreen.
So, ihr seht ja auch, hier ist die Windows-Maus
Hat mit Linux gar nichts zu tun
Was ich jetzt noch zusätzlich habe ist
Ich hab hier noch Deskflow
Deskflow ist ein Maus- und Tastatursharing-Tool
Wo man die Maus und Tastatur zwischen Linux und Windows sharen kann
Und jetzt hab ich so gemacht, ich mach das jetzt hier mal auf Fullscreen
Jetzt hab ich so gemacht, wenn ich jetzt hier mit einem Makro
Das kann ich euch auch gleich noch zeigen
mit einem Makro umschalte, dann switcht er auch direkt die Maus auf Linux.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Moment, wir gehen jetzt nochmal zurück.
In Deskflow habe ich Hotkeys angelegt.
Wenn ich Alt und Ö drücke, dann switcht er auf mein Windows zurück mit der Maus.
Und wenn ich auf Alt und Ä drücke, dann switcht er auf mein Linux.
guck, das kann ich euch jetzt hier gerade nochmal zeigen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier
Add drücke, seht ihr hier,
ist die Maus
jetzt hier drüben.
Im OBS-Fenster.
Und wenn ich jetzt wieder Ö drücke, bin ich hier wieder auf Windows
zurück. So, und dann habe ich mir
einen Makro gebaut.
Ups. Dann habe ich mir
einen Makro gebaut. Deswegen muss ich
auch immer diese Logitech-Software am Anfang starten.
Die immer
drei Stunden braucht.
Da habe ich mir ein Makro gebaut für Taste F1 und F2.
Und die drückt jetzt folgendes.
Die drückt jetzt Windows, Control und Pfeiltaste.
Damit switcht man zwischen den Desktops.
Und dann Alt-Ä oder Alt-Ö.
Je nachdem, wohin ich switchen will.
So, und jetzt drücke ich hier eine Taste.
Zack, lande ich auf dem zweiten Desktop
Und er switcht rüber
Guck, da ist der High wieder, er switcht rüber auf Linux
Und ich drücke eine andere Taste, ich switch zurück auf Windows
Gar nicht overengineert
Das ist ein bisschen overengineert, aber sag mir ein besseres Setup
Beziehungsweise das, wo ich das gleiche mit machen kann
Was einfacher funktioniert
Und genauso gut
Also läuft auf deinem Windows zweimal OBS
Eins zum Stream und eins für Linux
Richtig, Streaming OBS
Und hier
beziehungsweise hier auf dem zweiten Nest Hop
im Prinzip einfach nur
OBS für
also da bin ich jetzt auch
gar nicht so angewiesen auf OBS
wenn es eine Möglichkeit gibt
möglichst latency free
das Capture Card
Window
anzuzeigen, dann würde ich das auch machen
aber ich habe es mal mit VLC probiert
das ist laggy, das funktioniert nicht richtig
deswegen OBS
wäre ein KVM-Switch
nicht entspannter. Ne,
KVM-Switch würde nicht funktionieren,
weil
erstens könnte ich da nicht meine Overlay-Sachen
verwenden, die ich jetzt ja benutzen
kann. Hier haben wir ein Windows
Overlay-Tool.
Ja, für Sounds
und alles mögliche.
Und ich würde
dann auch quasi den Monitor wirklich umschalten
zwischen Windows
und Linux.
ich will jetzt gleichzeitig auch noch maus sharing zwischen windows und meinem
streaming vorschau pc hier auf der linken seite und ich möchte halt schnell
umschalten können also das alles in kombination geht eigentlich nur so hast
du teams gehört nee kann nicht sein ich habe kein teams laufen tiger vnc
funktioniert nicht so gut tiger vnc mit 240 hertz kannst vergessen
und
VNC, das ist was, wenn ich irgendwas
Remote machen will, aber nicht, wenn ich das
möglichst latency-free, 240
Hertz mit allem drum und dran und
Videos gucken und sowieso
benutzen will. Da ist VNC nicht so geil.
Alternative wäre ein Linux-VM.
Ich hatte jahrelang ein Linux-VM
am Laufen.
Das hatte ich gleiches Setup.
VM auf dem zweiten Desktop
und Windows auf dem ersten Desktop
oder Windows auf dem ersten und zweiten, aber Fullscreen
vor allem habe ich auf dem hier, hatte ich hier laufen
die ganze Zeit. Ich bin absichtlich
umgestiegen jetzt
von
der vor allem Workstation
vor allem
auf ein Native
hier ist es ja noch, auf ein Native
Linux, weil
weil
ich die Vermutung
habe
dass X immer weiter, also
X11 immer weiter ausgefacet
wird, was man jetzt ja auch sieht
das letzte Gnome Release
hat kein X mehr und sowas, also
dass X immer weniger supportet wird
und Wayland funktioniert in der VM
nur sehr mäßig
von gar nicht bis
nicht richtig
so, das heißt
Wayland in der VM fällt flach
das einzige, wo Wayland
halbwegs brauchbar funktioniert,
ist mit KDE,
aber
selbst da ist es von der
Performance her eklig und vor allem
wenn man backt rum und so, das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Das heißt, es blieb mir eigentlich nichts anderes übrig, wie eine
Native Linux Kiste hinzustellen.
Hat auch den weiteren Vorteil,
ich kann so Sachen wie GPU Decoding
und sowas verwenden, dass dann auch Videos
GPU Decoded laufen und so.
Also es ist eigentlich ein gutes Setup.
Max, das hat so nochmal für eine Reaktionszeit 100, 152, 155 Millisekunden oder sowas.
Hat dein aktuelles Setup eine Latenz?
Ja, 10 bis 15 Millisekunden oder so.
10 Millisekunden irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Wir haben das letztens ausprobiert.
Ich habe einen Reaktionstest gemacht unter Windows.
Da war das ungefähr so 150, 155 Millisekunden.
und dann haben wir einen Reaktionstest gemacht
und Linux, da war das so
165, 170 Millisekunden.
Also das ist
nicht spürbar.
Würde ich da drauf irgendwelches Pro-Gaming-Zeug
betreiben? Nee.
Aber für Linux im Terminal
benutzen, browsen und sonst was,
ist das, es ist, also
ich würde sagen, es ist keine Latency
festzustellen, ja.
Tja, und das, und das
mit 42.
Mit fast 42, Leute.
Ich würde mal behaupten,
ich bin mit meiner 155 Millisekunden
Reaktionszeit und 42
wahrscheinlich echt unter den
Top-Prozent.
Das
sage ich jetzt aber, weil irgendwie freut mich
das, ja.
Was wäre mit einer Proxmox VM und Display durch?
Da hast du ja das gleiche Problem, dass du da hin und her schalten musst.
Nee, das ist nix.
Außerdem, außerdem, müsste ich mich da mit Nvidia unter Linux rumschlagen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Für mich ist wirklich mit Abstand das einfachste Setup.
Hier mein Windows-Ding mit allem, was ich da drauf machen will.
Und für alles andere hier eine Linux-Kiste.
Das ist doch, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, ist das doch das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Ein vollständiges, vollwertiges Linux mit allem was man braucht und ein vollständiges, vollwertiges Linux.
Kein Extra.
Ganz ehrlich, dieser Mini-PC braucht eitel 8 Watt.
Wen juckt's?
Latency steht doch im Log von OBS, steht das das?
Und wie möchte OBS das feststellen?
Wie hoch die Latency ist?
Also ich glaube, es gibt da wenig Verlässlicheres.
Einfach 5-6 Mal Reaktionstest gemacht unter Windows, immer so ungefähr das gleiche rausgekommen.
Und dann das gleiche nochmal 5-6 Mal gemacht unter Linux.
und immer konstant irgendwie 10 15 Millisekunden mehr kann man denke ich
schon sagen sie mit den Latency wird irgendwie so zwischen 10 und 15 Millisekunden liegen
ich bin am überlegen wie ich mein Arbeitslaptop am besten auf meine Linux Kiste
streame zwischendurch
mal mit P KVM gelöst
ich hab hier ich hab ich hab ich hab hier ne KVM
da ist die Latency ganz okay
und zwar habe ich hier eine
GL-Net, KVM.
Aber ich sage jetzt nicht, dass du die kaufen sollst.
Also wirklich, das Gegenteil würde ich dir empfehlen.
Ich wollte es dir bloß mal zeigen.
Ich habe hier eine KVM am Start, die da.
Die ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Die geht über WebRTC und die Latency ist okay.
Also ich würde damit nicht täglich arbeiten wollen, aber die Latency ist okay.
So, also so viel KVM.
Ich glaube, das Beste ist tatsächlich, wenn du die Linux-Kiste auf dein Desktop-PC streamen willst, eine Capture Card.
Eine PCI-Express-Capture Card.
Ich weiß allerdings nicht, wie gut beispielsweise die Elgato 4K... Wie heißt dieses Ding nochmal? Wartet mal.
Wie heißt dieses Ding nochmal?
Elgato 4K Pro.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das unter Linux
funktioniert.
Aber ansonsten
finde ich mein Setup hier eigentlich
am besten.
Wo du dann natürlich ein Problem hast, ist
wie kriegst du die Maus und Tastatur
rüber? Kannst du
auf deinem Arbeitslaptop Sachen installieren
oder geht das nicht?
Und willst du nur
Willst du quasi vom Arbeitslaptop die Laptop-Tastatur verwenden und nur deinen Bildschirm-Output streamen?
Also ich finde, da ist eine Capture Card auf jeden Fall mal eine Überlegung wert.
Das dürfte die Latency-Freeze-Option sein.
Also ich glaube einen besseren Latency Test
Wie du klickst von Hand
Kannst du doch gar nicht machen
Weil das ist die komplette Ausgabe
Vom Bildschirm, du musst es sehen
Und die komplette Eingabe
Von deiner Hand über die Maus und Tastatur
an den Browser. Das ist quasi einmal
komplett Roundtrip Reaktionstest
machen.
Da hast du ja wirklich alles drin.
Also bei der Capture Card ist das glaube ich
kein Problem. Die kann...
Die Elgato kann glaube ich sogar
FreeSync.
Kann die? Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal.
Elgato 4K Pro Free Sync.
Hat die das?
Ja.
Siehste?
Es funktioniert.
Und Chat,
das ist wirklich gut.
Ihr erkennt jetzt ja keinen Unterschied,
dass das über eine Capture Card läuft oder nicht.
Vielleicht,
Vielleicht geht es auch...
Muss es eine Elgato sein?
Was?
Ne, es muss wahrscheinlich keine Elgato Capture Card sein.
Ich habe aber keine andere jetzt hier ausprobiert.
Ich habe mir die gekauft, weil es eine PCI Express Capture Card ist.
Und es einen Latency Test gab, irgendwo auf YouTube, wo das einer getestet hat.
Und die Latency halt wirklich sehr gering ist.
Kann die Capture Card auch mehrere Screens...
Ne, du hast nur einen HDMI Input.
Äh, ja, in der, in der, in der Elgato-Software, oder?
Oder hatten die, jetzt muss ich mal gucken hier.
Ich kann dieses Wort nicht schreiben.
Wie schreibt man das? Schreibt man das so? So, oder?
Wulnerabilities.
Oder war das Stream Deck?
Meinst du das hier?
Latest Stream Deck Update came with a Trojaner?
Weil ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie eine Capture Card
angreifbar sein sollte.
Die hängt ja nicht am Netz oder so.
Das ist ein falsches Positiv.
Was meinst du?
Mit was die Dinger für Probleme hatten?
Das ist mir nichts bekannt jetzt.
Ach, die KVM-Dinger.
Critical IP
Flaws.
Aha, lass mal kurz lesen.
Neun Critical IP KVM
Flaws enable unauthenticated
root access across four vendors.
Aha.
Äh, wo ist das Problem jetzt?
Unauthenticated Root Access.
Ja, gut.
Wen juckst, ich hab die bei mir im lokalen Netzwerk hängen.
Ja, das juckt mich nicht.
Das hängt bei mir lokal im Netzwerk drin.
Kommt keiner von außen dran.
Die haben wohl irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
Remote zu tunneln, aber das habe ich nicht eingeschaltet.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Genau, also ganz ehrlich,
Warum sollte man sowas ernsthaft ins Internet hängen?
Oder okay, was ich auch noch gette ist, wenn man das beispielsweise in irgendeinem Firmennetzwerk hat
und da kein eigenes Netzwerk für Managementinfrastruktur, dass die Leute da irgendwie drankommen.
Okay, dann, aber selbst dann, das, ne.
Also, sehe ich jetzt zumindest jetzt akut erstmal kein Problem.
So, ich wollte das Video eigentlich fertig gucken.
70 Tage Linux.
Damit das überhaupt funktionieren kann, muss Windows natürlich aktuell bleiben.
Diese Wartungszeit habe ich aber in meiner Rechnung sehr unterschätzt.
Einmal pro Woche habe ich ein Update gefahren und am Ende hat mich das mehr Zeit gekostet als alles andere.
7 Updates in 8 Wochen waren vollkommen problemlos.
Das hat gepasst.
Tja, Windows Updates.
Was bei Windows halt bedeutet, ca. 30 Minuten Zeit investieren.
Aber okay.
Aber in einer Woche gab es dann dafür richtig Probleme.
Ich startete gutgläubig den Update-Prozess. 1%, 2%, 3%, 4, 5, 6%, 7, 8%.
Meldung, dein PC ist nicht für Windows 11 geeignet.
Mein PC, auf dem Windows 11 bereits installiert ist, seit vielen Monaten, ist nicht für Windows 11 geeignet.
Mein PC ist nicht für Windows 11 geeignet.
Ich habe mich dann durch das Internet gegraben, bis ich eine Lösung gefunden habe.
Schriftarten aus der EFI-Partition löschen, weil plötzlich dort zu wenig Platz ist.
Was? Da fuck, Alter!
Okay. Windows als Backup war also mehr Belastung als Backup,
abgesehen davon, dass ich Windows in dieser Zeit eigentlich sowieso nur zum Updaten gestartet habe.
Score 6 von 10 Punkten.
Nun zum Thema Absicherung.
Die Festplattenverschlüsselung, die hat funktioniert tadellos.
Ohne Passwort komme ich nicht in mein System rein. Passt. Fertig.
Das echte Highlight für mich sind aber die Snapshot-Rollbacks.
Das CacheOS habe ich genauso wie Windows wöchentlich abgedatet.
Einmal gab es Probleme mit AppArmor.
Das hat mir den Systemstart blockiert.
Eingefrorener Screen.
Okay, aber die Snapshots haben mich trotzdem gerettet.
Einfach den letzten funktionierenden Snapshot gewählt, den Fehler gefixt und das abgedatet.
Das finde ich übrigens auch sehr nice unter CacheOS,
dass das automatisch, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas installiere,
so keine Ahnung, gibt es, wenn ich nach CAC W suche,
nach CAC, gibt es tatsächlich was, wenn man nach CAC sucht.
chat ich muss mal irgendwas installieren gerade euch das zeigen kann
was kann ich denn mal installieren gerade htob habe ich schon drauf
sunshine sunshine brauche ich nicht irgendwas kleines unsinniges b top ok b
top ja also jetzt hat jetzt b top und ihr seht guck der macht hier der
macht hier einen snapshot das ist eigentlich richtig kann euch das mal
zeigen. Warte mal, das ist richtig, das ist
wirklich richtig cool.
Ich reboot jetzt, also, geht jetzt davon aus,
mein System ist kaputt, okay?
Ach Quatsch, der zeigt das irgendwie. Ich muss
euch das jetzt nicht zeigen. Ich glaube, der zeigt das jetzt im Video.
Zumindest hat es jetzt einen Snapshot erstellt
und ich kann im Boot-Menü
auf diesen Snapshot
zurückrollen, oder beziehungsweise diesen
Snapshot starten und dann diesen Snapshot zurückrollen.
Das ist mega nice.
Kann man überall auch von Hand
einrichten, aber ich finde es richtig cool,
dass CacheOS das
standardmäßig
mit dabei hat.
Update sauber durchgezogen.
Ja, guck, hier sieht man es nämlich.
Guck, hier sieht man es nämlich.
Da sieht er Snapshot, Snapshot, Snapshot.
Hier nebendran steht auch, bei welchem
Kommando das angelegt wurde.
Da kann man einfach zurückrollen. Finde ich super, dass sie das
standardmäßig integriert haben.
Gewählt, den Fehler gefixt und das Update
sauber durchgezogen. Kleiner Tipp am Rande.
Lest Fehlermeldungen genau.
Am Anfang habe ich gedacht, Nvidia-Treiber sind stult, weil ich im Stress einfach nicht genau hingeschaut habe und habe dann unnötig viel Zeit, sehr viel Zeit dafür verbraten.
Jedenfalls genau für solche Situationen sind Snapshots da und das ist für mich das Mittel der Wahl.
Volle 10 von 10 Punkten für diesen Punkt.
Kommen wir zur Software.
Als Entwickler nutze ich ja JetBrains Rider in Kombination mit Avalonia.
Rider, beste.
Da wurde ich auch nicht enttäuscht.
Für Konsolenanwendungen und einfachere Programme Visual Studio Code, weil es einfach performanter ist.
und in letzter Zeit verwende ich auch überraschenderweise
manchmal den eingebauten Standard-Editor
Kate, der ist auch ganz toll. Bei LibreOffice
musste ich am Anfang... Den habe ich glaube ich
seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr benutzt. Ein bisschen kämpfen,
weil die Layouts meiner alten Dokumente,
die habe ich noch unter Windows erstellt. Okay, ihr kennt
mich, Office verwende ich ja aus Prinzip nicht.
Nicht basten, das habe ich aber
über Ersatzschrift... Und wenn es unbedingt mal sein muss,
dann verwende ich
wie heißt es jetzt?
Microsoft 365
Co-Pilot App
über einen Browser löst
und der Rest OBS, Teams, VPN, GIMP
und und und, alles wie erwartet.
Web-Apps habe ich direkt mit dem Brave Browser in die Taskleiste gelegt.
Super komfortabel, nutze ich jeden Tag
und ist wirklich praktisch. Aber Abstriche
gibt es trotzdem. Ich wollte ursprünglich
Kdenlive als mein Hauptprogramm für den Videoschnitt
verwenden, aber beim Rändern
meines dreistündigen SQL-Videokurses
muss ich leider wieder zu DaVinci Resolve Studio greifen.
Nicht wegen der Bedienung, sondern einfach nur
wegen der Rendergeschwindigkeit.
Außerdem, aber das war eh bekannt,
läuft WPF und Vimforms nicht nativ.
Daher zwei Punkte Abzug.
Acht von zehn Punkten.
Nun zu dem Punkt, der für mich absolut kritisch war.
Ich betreue ja Kundschaft mit C-Sharp-Projekten
und .NET-Anwendungen, die noch an Windows und WPF gebunden sind.
Da kann ich nicht einfach sagen,
hallo, ich bin jetzt auf Linux umgestiegen, steigt bitte auch um.
Dafür habe ich eine virtuelle Maschine mit QMU eingerichtet.
16 GB RAM, vier Kerne.
Ja gut, kann man machen.
Visual Studio läuft da drinnen perfekt.
Der Vorteil, ich muss den Linux-Host eigentlich nie verlassen.
Darin habe ich dann sogar Teile meines SQL-Kurses erstellt,
einfach damit ich die visuelle Konsistenz halten kann.
Aber, und jetzt kommt das große Aber,
sobald Windows in der virtuellen Maschine läuft
und du mit sensiblen Daten und Internet arbeitest,
fangen wieder ein bisschen die Probleme an.
Du brauchst ein Antivirenprogramm.
Ich habe dann von Avast zu Norton gewechselt.
Was? Es reicht Windows Defender und gut ist.
Mehr braucht man doch da beim besten Willen nicht.
Zusätzliche Kosten dadurch verursacht und das ist einfach nervig.
Deshalb von mir für diesen WPF-Workflow 8 von 10 Punkten.
Und jetzt zu meinem persönlichen Highlight, dem heimlichen Star meines Setups,
mein kleiner Touch-Monitor.
Ursprünglich war das Teil eigentlich nur für ein paar Kleinigkeiten gedacht,
Spielereien für die Uhrzeit, CPU-Last, RAM-Usage,
so Dinge, die man einfach gerne nebenher im Auge hat, wenn man arbeitet.
Aber ich habe das Ganze in der Testphase ein bisschen ausgebaut.
Ganz ehrlich, CPU-Usage habe ich auch hier oben.
Reicht mir.
Ich finde das so krass,
dass so ein Mini-PC einfach mal 16 CPU-Kerne anzeigt.
Was ja nicht stimmt.
Das sind 8 16 Threads.
Alles schon krass, oder?
So ein kleiner, poplischer Mini-PC.
Mittlerweile ist es wirklich meine zentrale Steuereinheit.
Ich steuere meine Audio-Outputs,
habe mir eigene Skripte geschrieben,
um die Elgato Keylights zu schalten.
Meine Büroleuchte, die eigentlich alles andere als smart ist,
habe ich mit einer Tasmotor-Steckdose verbunden.
Und über ein kleines Skript kann ich die jetzt auch
über dieses kleine Touch-Display steuern.
Wahnsinn, dieses eigentlich billige Display steuert fast mein gesamtes Büro.
Ich bin am überlegen mittlerweile, das Ganze auf eine größere Variante aufzurüsten,
weil es einfach so unfassbar praktisch ist.
Für die Lösung, die einfach nur funktioniert, 10 von 10 Punkten.
So, rechnen wir das Ganze mal zusammen.
Workflow und Performance.
Der hat das, wo Tasmota schon vorinstalliert kommt. Wieso? Ist doch gut.
Performance, 9 von 10 Punkten. Das System läuft.
Die 10-Minuten-Regel, nur 6 von 10 Punkten, mein Sorgenkind.
Natürlich die echten Hardcore-Tasmota-User, die flashen das selbst, weil du weißt ja sonst nicht, was drauf geflasht ist.
Windows hat eher gebremst als geholfen. Absicherung und Snapshots. Volle 10 von 10 für mich.
Er ist super happy damit, würde ich sagen.
Das Ergebnis ist für mich eigentlich eindeutig. Ich bin nicht mehr in irgendeiner Testphase.
Also wir wissen jetzt, er ist happy mit seinem Setup. Kann ich verstehen.
Aber das finde ich mal gut, dass man einen .NET-Entwickler sieht.
Der wichtigste, okay, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Oh, das müssen wir nachher auch noch, nee, das müssen wir nicht gucken.
Wir müssen nachher noch Techno-Tim gucken, wo ich mich wieder ein bisschen drüber lustig machen kann.
Dass er Sachen zum Management fürs Management laufen hat.
Der wichtigste Ort im Internet.
Okay, mal gucken, ob das stimmt.
Das ist aber nicht der wichtigste Ort im Internet.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das der wichtigste Ort im Internet ist.
Eines der wichtigsten Orte im Internet dürfte auf der Hanauer Landstraße sein.
In Frankfurt.
Also den Standort, wo das Internet bzw. die Server stehen, die das alles überhaupt erst möglich machen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist einfach ein Random-Rechtenzentrum.
Hier kann nicht jeder einfach rumlaufen, wie er möchte.
Okay, nee, das müssen wir nicht gucken.
Weil das ist eins der...
Hier, das ist natürlich ein Apparat.
Da gibt es was, was wir uns auch noch anschauen.
Kältetechnik.
Schon mal gesehen.
Das ist auch nicht immer sonderlich groß.
Und irgendwie sieht man wenig Server.
Es ist doch nicht mal sonderlich groß.
Wobei man das jetzt nicht wirklich sieht.
Das sieht auch eher so aus, als ob es so ein extra Gang ist,
dass es mit dem Airflow richtig passt.
Naja.
Es ist halt ein Rechenzentrum, ne?
Okay
Schreibt man die nicht anders?
Die schreibt man noch anders
Ich glaube nicht
Equinox oder sowas
Ich weiß nicht, in der Kaiserstraße ist das...
Äh, nicht in der Kaiserstraße.
In der Kleierstraße ist das...
Kaiserstraße.
Keck, weh.
Oder auch nicht mehr.
Früher war das mal in der Kleierstraße.
Ja.
Da waren die früher mal.
Kleierstraße.
Genau.
Ja, da war ich schon.
Aber nicht drinnen.
An dem Standort.
So, also dann gucken wir doch mal,
was TechnoTim so in seinem Homelab laufen hat.
Ich weiß, das ist wahrscheinlich...
Oder ich, was ich weiß.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich gehe stark davon aus,
dass das wieder ein typisches TechnoTim
Video ist, ich habe
5 Proxmox
Dinger laufen und 5 Monitoring
Lösungen und
5 Monitoring Lösungen
fürs Monitoring und 3
Nasses und 3 extra
Nasses fürs Monitoring
3 Kubernetes Cluster
die am Endeffekt 5 Pieholes
hosten und sowas in der Richtung
das ist wahrscheinlich
wieder so ein typisches TechnoTim Video
ich hab Hardware
und Sachen drauf, um sich selbst zu managen.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob er was Sinnvolles mittlerweile hostet.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Das frage ich mich jedes Mal, wenn ich das sehe von dem.
Monitoring, ja, wahrscheinlich ist die Hälfte davon Monitoring.
Der Kerl hat doch, na gut, ich weiß nicht, ob er nur einen Rack hat, aber braucht man wirklich sowas dafür?
Ich meine, es ist cool zum angucken, aber es ist letztendlich auch so eine Management-Software zu managen.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
of media like plex fotos in transkode dafür leute leute für für image hosting brauchst du
mindestens ja so wie der techno tim mindestens fünf box box box in fünf anna box box cluster
und drei kubernetes cluster anders 3.0 anders geht auf gar keinen fall dax in real life apps
Das haben wir in der letzten Sache ausprobiert.
Okay, Management zu managen.
Lass mal kurz gucken, das ist ja nicht einmal sonderlich viel.
Okay, also haben wir 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Ne, Moment, das sind Container.
1, 2, 3, 4 VMs?
Und?
Und nochmal 4 VMs?
Ja, WTF?
8 VMs?
Leute, das kannst du auf Mini-PC laufen lassen oder auf irgendeinem x-beliebigen NAS.
Weil viel Last werden die Dinger ja wohl nicht haben.
Der hat die fertigen Scripts benutzt.
Ja, das habe ich auch gesehen, aber das mache ich nicht.
Das einzige Skript, was ich benutzt habe, ist das für Post Install, das ein bisschen
hübscher machen.
Aber ansonsten wird das selbst installiert.
Backups with PBS and even some LXC's this year and then TrueNAS as my storage layer.
moment das heißt er hat ein box cluster mit jeweils vier vms pro note darauf ein kuba netz
dann hat er noch einen schulers was nicht darauf läuft und darauf hatte auch noch mal containers
Okay, was wir hiervon sehen, ist im Endeffekt
Infrastruktur
und
Monitoring zum größten Satz. Also,
wir haben, okay, Plex für Media-Stells,
Traffic, Reverse-Proxy-Gedöns,
Media, Media, Media, Media,
DNS, nochmal ein DNS,
Keepalive-D,
whatever das da macht, Home Assistant,
ZigBee-To-MQTT,
das zählt ja alles zu Home Assistant, das da, Codeserver, whatever,
Monitoring, Monitoring, Monitoring, nochmal,
okay, der benutzt Up-Down-Monitoring, also für so Availability-Zeug,
Uptime-Kuma und für Metriken und Logs, Low-Key,
ähm, was war Alloy nochmal?
Das ist von Grafana, doch, oder was, Prometheus?
Das ist doch dieser Agent, oder?
Grafana Alloy, das ist dieser Agent, den man anstatt dem Prometheus-Agent installieren kann?
War das nicht die Geschichte?
Ohne Datenbank, okay.
Ja, Tiny Small, deswegen verstehe ich das auch nicht.
Das ist total over-engineert.
Das Internet.
Immerhin, guck dir mal hier.
Der hat einfach mal 25
Gig.
Ist das Link Aggregation?
Lack?
Also sind das keine
wirkliche 25 Gig, sondern
ähm, was denn?
5 Gig?
Oder wie kommt man auf 25
sonst?
Oder ist es
zweimal? Oder meint er damit
zweimal 25
Gig, dass falls eins ausfällt
oder so?
J-Law, da musst du jetzt durch.
Okay, das kann ich verstehen, ja.
Das ist bei mir auch so.
Also ähnlich.
Ich habe einen IoT-WLAN,
da darf nichts ins Internet und sowas.
Dann habe ich eins fürs WLAN,
ein extra WLAN für WLAN-Geräte.
Also für normale Smartphones, Drucker
und sowas und halt das default wlan für intern alles andere also muss er nicht übertreiben
ok das können wir mal skippen das müssen wir uns ja angucken
moment
Ich habe auch noch verschiedene Server, die eine Kollokation haben und die ich nicht zu
weit von hier habe und es gibt drei Server, die ich bewohnen und behalten, wo einige meiner
Services laufen.
Ich meine cool, aber warum?
Für Backups oder was?
Warum hat das Server in irgendeinem Rechenzentrum rumstehen, wo ist der Sinn davon?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Seriously?
100.000 Zugriffe?
Das ist ja nicht mal...
Das erinnert mich an die Geschichte.
Das habe ich euch, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt.
Wir hatten mal auf der alten Arbeit...
Hatten wir mal ein Meeting mit Leuten,
die wollten irgendeinen neuen Service bei sich hosten.
und die haben als erstes gleich gesagt,
Max, wir brauchen die fettesten
Kisten, die ihr so habt.
Ich so, oi, boah, was habt ihr denn da vor?
Klingt ja, klingt ja hier
richtig, äh, quasi
nach viel Traffic und allem,
was habt ihr denn vor und was habt, was
heißt denn fette Kisten und warum und
mit wie viel Request rechnet ihr?
Da haben die dann gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr, was es genau
war, ich sag jetzt einfach mal irgendeine Zahl.
Da haben die dann auch gesagt, äh, Request
10.000.
Was? 10.000 Requests pro Sekunde?
Boah, geht ja ab.
Nee, nee, keine Ahnung.
Am Tag oder so.
Okay, ich bring euch demnächst mal
ein Raspberry Pi mit.
Ein Raspberry Pi Zero am besten noch.
10.000 pro Sekunde,
hätte ich gesagt, okay, da geht ja was.
Aber am Tag, das ist ja nix.
Das ist komplett nix.
Das Grundrauschen, ey.
Und das ist, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich so was
hosten würde, der
hostet ja irgendeinen Blog oder so,
dann würde ich das, also die Idee,
das als Markdown zu schreiben, als Markdown
rauszuholen, das finde ich nicht schlecht, glaube, das habe ich da
eben rausgehört.
Aber wenn ich das wirklich selbst hosten will,
dann würde ich das
auf irgendeiner
Kiste in der Hetzner Cloud hosten
oder sowas, wenn ich da einen eigenen
Server für haben
wollte. Ehrlich gesagt, würde ich
mir da gar keinen echten Server für holen,
sondern würde wahrscheinlich irgendwie GitHub
Pages oder irgendwie sowas machen.
Dann muss ich mich gar nicht drum kümmern und kostet nichts.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, wenn die
gemeint hätten, pro Sekunde hätten die schon pro Sekunde
gesagt. Also den Sinn, habt ihr jetzt rausgehört, warum er Server in der Co-Location stehen hat?
Und vor allem, warum es eigene Server in der Co-Location sein müssen und nicht irgendwelche
publischen Cloud-VMs es tun? Weil er es geil findet. Ja geil finde ich es auch, aber sinnvoll nicht.
Ach guck mal, es sind tatsächlich mehr VMs. Es sind drei Cluster-Nodes mit jeweils vier VMs drauf.
Okay, ein DNS, zwei DNS, okay, mehrere DNS, was auch immer.
Also im Prinzip ist der Proxmox Cluster eigentlich nur dafür da, einen Kubernetes Cluster zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und Unify läuft da noch drauf.
Okay.
Jaja, das kann man schon machen.
Aber ob das so sinnvoll ist, sei mal dahingestellt jetzt.
Das macht schon Sinn.
Proxmox Backup Server macht ja auch irgendwie die Duplication und sowas.
Das ist schon nett verkehrt.
I'm running HA LXCs or HA Virtual Machines and I'm not.
Du kannst maximal zwei DNS-Server einstellen.
Ja, aber was der gemacht hat ist,
der hat einen DNS-Server, der hat eine IP
und dann hat er zwei weitere DNS-Server geklustert
mit einer virtuellen IP oder mit einem Loadbalancer davor.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Das heißt, er stellt weiterhin nur zwei DNS-Server ein,
aber in Wirklichkeit sind da drei dahinter.
Warum? Man weiß es nicht.
Okay, Chad, ich wette mit euch.
Ich wette mit euch.
Der hatte bei sich daheim schon mehr Ausfälle oder Probleme durch High Availability, als die High Availability vermieden hat.
Weil das wird immer unterschätzt, ja, das ist extra overhead, sowohl gedanklich als auch hardwaremäßig als auch konfigurationsmäßig und sogar im Business Enterprise Umfeld habe ich das erlebt, dass es Ausfälle gegeben hat wegen Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen.
Ja, sei es irgendwelche Split-Brain-Geschichten oder wo man die Netzwerk, ja einmal da haben die Netzwerkswitche übelst rumgespackt beim Spanning-Tree neu aufbauen. Also wir hatten relativ viele Ausfälle, die durch Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen gekommen sind.
Gegenargument kann ich jetzt nicht wirklich bringen,
weil ich natürlich nicht genau weiß,
so 100% welche
Ausfälle vermieden wurden, weil
die wurden ja vermieden, ja.
Also ich weiß es höchstens bei so Sachen wie
Disks gehen kaputt
oder Server kackt ab
und es hat erfolgreich umgeschwenkt
und sowas, aber wie viel da ist wirklich,
kann ich nicht sagen, aber wir hatten
definitiv einige Ausfälle
durch Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen,
die wir nicht gehabt hätten,
bei weniger komplexen Setups.
So, und was ich mich auch noch frage,
ist, weil es der Chat gerade schreibt,
das zu managen alles,
ist ja fast ein zusätzlicher Job.
Du musst dir das T-Shirt kaufen.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Cosplaying als Server-Admin.
Das finde ich witzig.
Verschicken die? Verschicken die nach Deutschland?
Also 4XL muss schon sein.
Näh.
Das ist schlimm, mittlerweile passe ich sogar in L wieder rein.
Dann nehmen wir mal XL.
Verschicken die nach Deutschland?
Checkout.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Store-Info.
Wie es mir geht?
Ja, ganz okay.
Immer noch so meine Probleme.
Aber objektiv gesehen wird es besser.
US-Shipping.
international shipping wie okay also international shipping
ok
ja denn ich glaube sowas bestelle ich mir finde ich ganz witzig
und dann auch
Noch mehr Nodes.
Ah, guck mal, da läuft sogar ein bisschen mehr drauf noch auf seinen Co-Location.
Der hat auch Proxmox in den Co-Location.
Was hat er denn da noch? Postgres, HA-Proxy, MongoDB, MySQL.
What the fuck?
Achso, das sind Container. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
das ist ja eine wilde Mischung aus allem.
Postgres, MongoDB, MySQL,
Redis.
Da hat er noch einen Rancher.
Also wahrscheinlich hat er da sein Kupernet, das mit
Rancher laufen. Vermutlich noch einmal
ein DNS.
Und noch mal Kupernet. Okay.
Keine Ahnung, blicken wir durch.
Ist nicht der Sinn von Nodes, dass das theoretisch verteilt werden kann,
sodass du dann die zwei auch durchaus auf Mainzer haben kannst?
Also ich finde das auch sinnvoll,
aber spätestens wenn der Node mal ausfällt, dann ist es ja eh wild verteilt.
Aber vom Ansatz her finde ich nicht verkehrt.
virtual machines running multiple nodes and making those for example
postgres postgres 1 in lx postgres 2 in lx sie in postgres 3 in lx warum warum warum hat er
dann dreimal postgres und mongol db und mysql okay wo wir wieder dabei sind er hat halt hauptsächlich
Sachen, um sich selbst zu verwalten.
So.
These are running in an Postgres Cluster Petroni.
The same with Redis, the same with MongoDB, HAProxy.
So if any one of these goes down, the cluster will continue to run.
I could take this.
Warum es drei sind, verstehe ich schon, wenn es im Cluster ist.
Aber was hat er denn für einen Anwendungszweck für den Postgres Cluster so?
und all diese Services werden für den meisten Teil weiter funktionieren.
Das gleiche gilt für meine Kubernetes-Node.
Ich habe mein ETSID und Control Plane und einen Arbeiter,
mit einer Rancher-Node hier.
Und dann habe ich das gleiche auf 2 und 3.
Und wiederum kann ich jede einer dieser herunternehmen
und meine Services sollten für den meisten Teil aufstehen.
Für den Storage benutze ich immer noch TrueNAS Scale.
TrueNAS ist die Homebase für all meine Daten.
Und dieses Jahr wurde es auch die Homebase für viele meiner Applikationen.
Du kannst sehen, dass ich noch ein bisschen...
seine anwendung auch auf tunas packt was macht dann das andere zeug besser haben als brauchen
das stimmt guckst du bei dem spruch muss jemand denken guckst du zufällig bauforum 24 auf youtube
die sagen das auch immer
bambus to the bambus studio
zum
... aber es wird auch wo meine internen Applikationen leben.
Sobald ich es herausgefunden habe, ...
Ach, jetzt sehen wir hier gerade seine Docker Compose Files und sowas.
Okay, eigentlich ganz cool.
Wenn
Trunas Docker Compose
kann,
kann Trunas
auch normale VMs?
Vielleicht sollten wir doch mal
TrueNAS ausprobieren
Mal wieder
ausprobieren
Wir können es auf einem der drei Nasskisten
noch ausprobieren, TrueNAS
Ich hab doch jetzt genug Nasskisten
Das muss ich mal aufschreiben
TrueNAS
auf dem Ukraine
ProNAS. So.
Probieren wir das aus.
Was habe ich das jetzt? Moment, habe ich das jetzt richtig gehört?
Ist TrueNAS eine VM?
Nee, oder?
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Das hat 200 GB RAM.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil er sich von den FreeNAS-Forum-Leuten hat erzählen lassen,
das kannst du sonst vergessen
ZFS zu benutzen
gibt es eigentlich das
Freenas Forum noch?
ah das ist jetzt das Trunas Forum
ok
also das war früher
ganz schlimm
die haben dann auch gesagt
du musst ECC Rahmen haben
und haben so getan als wäre ZFS
ohne ECC-RAM
total fehleranfällig und schlechter als
andere Filesysteme.
Und du musst mindestens
1 GB RAM pro Terabyte
Speicher haben und sowas.
Gut, 1 GB RAM
pro 1 TB Speicher,
das war ja zwischenzeitlich
preislich auch überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber du musst beides nicht unbedingt
haben, das macht
ja alles Sinn im Business Enterprise Umfeld,
wenn du das so
so
sicher wie möglich laufen haben
möchtest, also auch was Fehlererkennung
und alles angeht und so performant
wie möglich laufen lassen
möchtest mit hunderten User,
die drauf zugreifen und sowas,
dann
mag das ja durchaus Sinn machen,
aber im Heimbereich,
im Leben nichts, braucht überhaupt nichts.
hilft gerade, wenn man kein ECC hat.
ZFS hilft auch, wenn man kein ECC hat.
Das ist totaler Blödsinn, dass du ECC haben musst.
Die ganze Checksum-Geschichte und sowas, die hilft auch ohne ECC.
Ja, Mehram ist nicht verkehrt.
Mehram ist immer gut.
Aber Leute,
Chat, Chat, das schlimmste Forum
ist immer noch...
Das ist immer noch
das schlimmste Forum. Sieht auch aus,
wie aus 1995,
ja.
Das ist immer noch das schlimmste
Forum, Alter.
Das Mikro...
Mikrocontroller-Forum.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal wieder,
ob's da...
Einfache Frage.
Okay, einfache Frage.
120 Antworten.
Da weißt du schon, was abgeht, Alter.
Okay, einfache Frage.
Okay, der kriegt sein
I2C-Display nicht zum Laufen.
Okay?
Okay, mal gucken, wie es losgeht.
Jetzt wird er erst mal belehrt, ob das korrekt ist, Zeichen zu sagen oder Grafiken.
Oh Gott, die Leute in diesem Forum, Alter.
Die Leute in diesem Forum, die sind so nervig, Alter.
Haltet doch einfach die Klappe, ey.
Es ist doch klar.
Es ist doch klar, was er wissen will, oder?
Dieses Forum, das ist wirklich das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
die haben sie die lassen sich jetzt 100 120
was geht denn hier schon wieder ab
was du was ist hier schon wieder los in dem forum einer
Dieses Forum, man.
Alter.
Das ist ohne Scheiß, das ist wirklich seit Jahren schon das schlimmste Forum, was ich so kenne.
Wisst ihr, was wir eigentlich mal machen müssten?
Wir müssten mal absichtlich so eine Ragebait-Frage stellen im Mikrocontroller-Forum.
Und wir müssen uns vorher überlegen, was ist der ragebaitigste Weg, eine Frage zu stellen?
also es muss auf jeden Fall auf die Art
und Weise sein, dass es
was offensichtlich falsch ist
aber der Post muss so
geschrieben sein, als wüsste ich
dass es richtig ist
weil nichts triggert Leute mehr
als andere Leute
im Internet darauf hinzuweisen, dass sie falsch liegen
genau
okay, guck mal, das war fertig hier
Ja, wisst ihr, was da auch ganz gut ist?
Wenn man einfach eine Kiste hat, anstatt drei und sonst was darüber logisch noch drüber
gespannt hat.
Fachbegriffe
falsch benutzen ist auch gut.
Komponenten falsch
bezeichnen. Ich glaube, man könnte
einen richtig heftigen Mikrocontroller
Forum Trigger Post schreiben.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, das ist eine gute
Idee. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Dass man irgendwie so, ja, ja, ja, das ist eine
gute Idee. Dass man irgendwie sowas schreibt wie
Okay, ich möchte mir ein eigenes NAS bauen. Ich habe gelesen, ein ESP32 ist da viel stromsparender als ein eigenes NAS. Wie bekomme ich denn da jetzt einen Windows-Share drauf? Irgendwie sowas Dummes oder so. Da flippen sie komplett aus.
AI Ragebait Post schreiben lassen.
Okay, wollen wir mal die AI fragen, was sie sagt?
Komm, fragen wir mal ChatGPT, okay?
Schreib mir den Ragebaitixten.
Oh, das kann ich nicht.
Rage-Batixen-Post.
Schreib mir einen.
Den Rage-Batixen-Post,
der dir einfällt
für das
Forum.
Okay.
Das versteht man.
Alles klar.
Ich gebe dir was,
das ziemlich sicher Antworten triggert,
aber ohne komplett unter...
Nein, warum?
sonst wirst du einfach nur gelöscht hier ist ein schön toxisch zerkaschen rage spät im typischen
microcontroller.net stil also warum ist hier eigentlich jeder zweite beitrag entweder arrogant
oder nutzlos oh das triggert auch gut das triggert auch gut das das ist nicht schlecht ja
das aber ich will lieber einen post der sich auf sp 32 controller bezieht
Warum empfehlen hier eigentlich alle blind
ESP32 für alles?
Das ist nicht gut
Das ist Trash, ne?
Okay, komm
Wir fragen mal, wollen wir mal gucken
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob die China-Chinesen-AI besser ist?
Wollen wir mal Kroc fragen?
Okay, wir fragen erst noch mal die China-Chinesen-AI.
Okay.
Okay, das überlegt.
Das ist tatsächlich.
Benutze
Fachbegriffe bewusst
falsch.
Es soll
um ESP32 gehen
und benutze Fachbegriffe
falsch.
Dann lassen wir die KI
nochmal neu hier mit drauf.
Google darf
auch noch.
und Chat-GPT darf auch nochmal.
So, jetzt mal gucken.
China-KI
versus Elon-KI versus
OpenAI versus irgendeine Gemini-Geschichte.
Das ist schon mal nicht
schlecht.
Das gefällt mir schon mal besser.
ESP32 mit 230 Volt
direkt schalten.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Hallo Leute, ich brauche mal kurz
eine Hilfe von den Profis.
Ich will mit einem ESP32, der ja viel besser ist als der veraltete STM32-Müll, den hier noch einige nutzen, meine Kaffeemaschine steuern.
Ich habe jetzt die 230 Volt-Leitung direkt an den GPIOs gelötet, weil ich dachte, der ESP...
Ah, okay, das ist zu auffällig. Das ist zu auffällig. Das erkennen die sofort, dass das G-Bait ist.
Das erkennen die sofort, dass das Verarschung ist.
Aber vom Stil her ist das schon mal gut.
Vom Stile her ist das schon mal gut.
Es geht in die richtige Richtung.
Der ESP32 hat da Internal Pull-Ups.
Die Spannung dann auf 32 Volt runter draußen.
Aber irgendwie raucht der Chip jetzt immer ab.
Der raucht nicht immer ab, der raucht genau einmal ab.
Nur das ganze Board mit.
Ich schätze, das liegt an der billigen China-Firma.
Welche Baudrate, Widerstand, muss ich in die Arduino IDE Beste Entwicklung
hier oben schreiben, damit die Frequenz, die CPU, die Voltzüge...
Das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich guter Post.
Der Post, also mit ein bisschen
Tuning wäre dieser Post, glaube ich,
echt ganz gut. Aber es ist zu,
genau, es ist zu offensichtlich, dass das
G-Bait ist.
Das ist, das ist,
ja, genau.
Mach den Rage-Bait
etwas weniger offensichtlich.
Um den
Bait subtiler zu gestalten, müssen
wir die Anfänge arrogant so verpacken,
dass die Forennutzer glauben, du meinst
es ernst. Ja.
Ich habe gerade...
Okay, das ist schon mal besser.
Effizienzfrage. Warum externer Pegelwandler,
wenn man Software-Mapping hat?
Hat sowas überhaupt nichts miteinander
zu tun, aber okay.
Das passt ja schon mal gut.
Ich arbeite gerade an einem größeren Smart Home Projekt auf ESP32 Basis.
Da ich das Design möglichst kompakt halten will, verzichte ich auf den ganzen unnötigen Ballast wie externe Optokoppler und diese klobigen Pegelwandler für die 230 Volt Sensoren.
Oh, das würde allein schon auch schon richtig hart die Leute trinken.
Wobei das immer noch ein bisschen zu offensichtlich ist, oder?
Das ist immer noch zu offensichtlich.
Guck mal, was die China-KI macht.
Wie komme ich ins BIOS?
Nee, das ist...
Aber der Anfang ist schon mal gut.
Ich bin seit 20...
Das ist immer gut, so dieses Autoritätsargument.
Ich benutze das schon seit 20 Jahren.
Ihr müsst mir erst gar nichts anderes erzählen.
Ich bin seit 20 Jahren in der IT tätig.
Hauptsächlich...
Nee, nee, nee, das ist viel zu offensichtlich, Tribade.
Nee, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist nicht gut.
Das ist zu offensichtlich auch.
Okay, was macht ChatGPT draus?
Okay, also mal ehrlich, versteht den Hype um den ESP2-Nice-Ding
ist doch im Grunde nur ein Chlorophyll.
Nee, das ist...
Also ganz ehrlich, da finde ich fast die...
Ach, was sagt denn
Kroc? Haben wir noch gar nicht geguckt.
Ähm...
ESP32 mit
Cortex-M7...
Nein, das ist auch dumm.
Das ist auch dumm.
Also da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
da fand ich das von diesem Gemini-Verschnitt
hier bei Google noch am besten.
Das muss aber auch noch...
müsste aber auch noch optimiert werden.
Ja, das ist aber nicht so richtig gut.
Hand-optimierter Ragebait
ist immer noch am besten.
Jetzt gucken wir mal weiter.
Leute, ich habe jetzt eine Stunde
geschwätzt oder so und wir haben 8 Minuten
von dem Video gepackt.
Classic.
Wupplos Classic.
Ich habe kein Login bei Claude.
Oder kann man das
online benutzen mit einem
Free Tier, ohne eingeloggt zu sein.
Geht das? Kann man das hier?
Nee, ne?
Muss man sich einloggen.
Try Clone.
Nee.
Arena.ai
Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
KI-Battle
Battle Mode. Okay.
Also, Battle. Zwei anonyme
Models.
Machen wir mal.
Oder Buy Choice.
Aber kann ich das jetzt...
Aber das muss...
Kann man das kostenlos machen?
Ja.
Was? Dabei kann ich dir nicht helfen.
Okay, Chat-GPT 5.4 erstmal richtig useless.
Okay, nice.
Ohne gezielt zu provozieren oder Streit anzuzetteln.
Chat-GPT kannst du vergessen.
zu vergessen. Okay, was
macht Claude Opus 4.6
Thinking?
Aber GPT
ist richtig schlecht, oder?
Ich habe bei meinem ESP32 das Problem, dass der
Prozessor wahrscheinlich thermisch ins RAM abstrahlt.
Das ist so wirr.
Das erkennt man sofort, ja.
Okay, was machen die?
ESP2 besser als
jeder Arm. Warum benutzt ihr noch
Okay, das ist auch dumm.
xxespkönigxx
Okay, den Namen finde ich schon mal gut.
xxiquickscopeshdxx
Dieser Post sollte auf
microcontroller.net mindestens 14 Seiten
antworten und drei gesperrte Threads erzeugen.
Ha, gut.
Naja, okay Leute, es braucht tatsächlich irgendwann mal handoptimierten Ragebait, sonst wird das
nix.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Wir machen ein, wir machen jetzt nicht den Post.
Was? Repli... Okay, was auch immer er noch da zusätzlich vorhat.
Wohin replicatet er denn jetzt? Zu seiner Co-Location oder what?
Ach so, der hat auch noch zwei TrueNASes. Ah, verstehe, verstehe.
Also ich bleib tatsächlich bei dem simplen, ich AirSynche es einmal nachts auf einer externen Platte.
So, how do we decide between Docker and Kubernetes?
Well, I decided that all of my home services are going to be Docker
on compose running on TrueNAS and then all of my public services
are going to be in Kubernetes running in my co-location.
Ja und? Und? Und?
Was? Was?
Und was läuft jetzt auf seinem Proxmox Kubernetes Cluster?
Nix? Oder wie?
Okay, was sehen wir hier? Also im Prinzip ist hier alles davon Management. Hier ist nichts dabei, was wirklich Services bereitstellt. Guck mal, Infrastruktur ist richtig Management. DNS, Gedöns, Monitoring, Zeug. Da ist nichts, was wirklich einen Mehrwert bietet, weil es gehostet wird.
Okay, Speedtest, ja sorry, Speedtest vielleicht. Aber warum man den auch immer selbst hosten muss?
Da ist nichts dabei.
Das alles ist alles zum sich selbst verwalten.
Wenn du dieses gleiche Dashboard willst, kann ich dir mein YAML schicken und du hättest das auch.
Ich mag es, die meisten meiner Sachen in Code zu managen. Du wirst das sehen.
Aber ich habe meine Homepage viel einfacher gemacht.
Wie du siehst, mache ich keine Up-Time-Auswahl.
Ich mache keine Service-Kollegen, also gehe ich nicht raus, um zu sehen, wie viele Maschinen ich blockiere oder wie viele VMs ich blockiere.
Und wirklich, das wurde einfach wieder meine Link-Page.
I do like the idea of these going out and fetching data and lighting up,
because every time I open a tab and go here...
Da ist immer noch nix, da ist immer noch nix, was wirklich gehostet wird.
KVM, KV... Moment, dann hat er aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
...sechs Jet-KVMs, sieben KVMs...
Okay, nochmal Management Interface.
Da ist bis jetzt nichts drin, was wirklich einen Mehrwert bietet, weil es halt benutzt werden kann.
Das ist alles nur für Management.
Monitoring, Remote Access, Storage...
Immer noch nix.
Immer noch nix wirklich Gehostetes, was man verwendet.
Oh, jetzt langsam, aber sicher.
Okay, äh, äh, äh, Media-Zeug.
Okay, ja.
UPS-Monitor, das kenn ich gar nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Ach.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, Nut kenne ich auch.
Das ist eigentlich ganz, ganz, ganz nice.
Kann man sich mal merken.
Okay, hier, hier, hier ist, hier ist mal wieder auch eine Sache, wo er, wo er benutzt.
Okay.
Paperless Tools.
Also, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
die einzigen Sachen,
die hier wirklich
Mehrwert bieten und gehostet werden,
ist Home Assistant,
irgendwelche Workflow Automation
und Media.
Der Rest
ist komplett, um sich selbst
zu verwalten und die Verwaltung zu verwalten
und das Monitor zu monitoren.
Das könntest du
mal streng genommen
alles auf
einer kleinen Nasskiste machen.
Überhaupt kein
Problem.
Wenn man mal jetzt von
Transcoding und Gedöns
und allem hier oben absieht,
das meiste wird sogar auf dem Raspberry
Pi ohne Probleme laufen.
Also sagen wir mal so,
Paperless mit AI nicht, Paperless alleine
ja, auf jeden Fall.
Home Assistant auch auf jeden Fall,
Unify auch auf jeden Fall.
und Foto-Hosting auch.
Das Einzige, was nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi läuft,
ist halt KI-Geschichten und
Media-Transcoding und sonst was.
Ne, da ist nicht 50% Productivity,
ich würde sagen
20%,
30%, wenn man mal sehr großzügig ist.
Wirkliche Anwendung und der Rest Infrastruktur, Selbstverwaltung, Monitoring-Kram.
Dafür brauchst du aber garantiert nicht drei Kubernetes-Cluster.
Ja, die 3-Node-Kubernetes-Klasse.
Ja, also, guck mal, er hat es doch sogar auf GitHub.
Da können das einfach bei GitHub Pages hosten.
Da braucht er keinen Server in irgendeiner Co-Location.
Link.
Ja, gut.
Moment.
Okay.
Für einen self-hosted Shortlink-Service.
Brauche ich was?
Was hat der jetzt erzählt?
Ich brauche einen Frontend-Container, einen Backend-Container,
einen API-Container, einen SQL-Container
und einen Redis-Container.
Okay, das ist ja schön und gut für High-Performance-Dinger
mit vielen Usern, ja.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ein Shortlink-Service für mein Kram daheim
und ein paar einzelne Aufrufe,
Da tut es ja sogar easy in der SQLite-Datenbank.
Also ich mag ja für die Dinge, also für solche Sachen daheim, gut das funktioniert nicht mit Kubernetes und Gedöns und so ohne weiteres, aber ich mag Nginx Proxy Manager, das ist so schön simpel, zweimal geklickt und fertig, neuer Endpunkt mit gültigem Zertifikat.
Du kannst doch das mit Let's Encrypt lokal machen.
Oder was meinst du?
Du kannst doch einfach sagen, lokal.
Das ist kein deutscher.
Nee, Ersatz ist irgendwie
ein EPG-Service
oder sowas, glaube ich.
Für Fernsehprogramme.
Irgendwie so, glaube ich.
Na klar geht Let's Encrypt offline.
Na klar.
Chatkill.
Was erzählt der denn hier wieder für Dinger?
Natürlich geht letztendlich Crypt offline
Doch
DNS Challenge, fertig
Das ist eigentlich ganz simpel
Du brauchst einen DNS Server
Bei beispielsweise Cloudflare
Achso, du willst deine eigene
CA nutzen
Ja gut, wenn du da ein...
Dann ist es natürlich ein größerer Akt
das ist das einfachste
aber es ist auch relativ easy mit DNS Challenge
einzelne Zertifikate für
unterschiedliche Services zu machen
zum Beispiel mit Nginx Proxy Manager
richtest da einmal deine DNS
deine DNS Challenge
ein
und dann geht das
du brauchst halt nur einen Anbieter
für deine Domain
beziehungsweise
Nameserver, der für deine Domain
zuständig ist, den du
per API ansprechen kannst. Aber das können ja
zum größten Teil alle.
Außer irgendwelche Nischen-Dinger, ja.
Sogar Pork-Bun kannst du mittlerweile.
Cloudflare schon ewig.
Bei Hetzner ist es, glaube ich, tatsächlich
ein bisschen schwieriger.
Obwohl es bei Hetzner auch funktioniert,
ein bisschen schwieriger, weil
wenn du dort Domains
betreiben willst, dann
fragen die dich im Zweifelsfall nach einem Ausweis
und sowas. Da habe ich immer keinen Bock drauf.
Deswegen läuft mein
ganzer Kempel bei Cloudflare.
Das einzig,
also ich habe die Domains
nicht alle bei Cloudflare, aber meine DNS
Sachen habe ich bei Cloudflare.
Das einzig dumme bei Cloudflare,
wie ich finde, ist,
wenn du dir Domains kaufen willst,
cloudflare bietet keine de domains an und ich verstehe einfach nicht warum immer noch nicht
mich haben die auch noch nicht gefragt aber ich hab da auch keine domains oder sowas
die gucken wir weiter
so using it as in ingress for all of my applications in kuban es verdienen es ein
still using pie hole am using it here at home and also in my co location to at home
ist ja ich müsste mal wieder gucken also ich habe ja mittlerweile keinerlei dns
Geschichten in der Richtung mehr daheim laufen,
weil Browser-Plugins
blocken einfach
eh besser und können auch
mehr blocken vom
Prinzip, wie sie funktionieren.
Das Einzige, wofür es ganz nice
war, war Mobile.
Aber da hast du auch zunehmend
das Problem, dass
Apps und
Smartphone-Sachen auf deine
Netzwerk-Config scheißen
und versuchen irgendwie dran vorbeizugehen.
Das letzte Mal, als ich
Edgar vs. Piehole
mal ausprobiert habe, hat mir Edgar
Home etwas besser gefallen.
Weiß nicht, wie das jetzt
mittlerweile ist.
Aber ich habe eh keinen mehr laufen.
aber ich verwende sie auch für lokalen DNS.
Wenn ich einen CNAME oder einen A-Rekord erstellen muss,
dann stelle ich es in Pi-Hole.
Und man könnte sich fragen,
ob das ein Splittbrain-Szenario ist?
Du hast drei Pi-Hole Instanzen.
Die Art, wie ich all diese synchronisiere,
ist durch Nebula Sync.
Nebula Sync ist ziemlich cool.
Es ist ein Container, das die Pi-Hole API
auf mehrere Pi-Hole Instanzen synchronisiert.
Und mit Pihole benutze ich Unbound,
der ein rekkurverter DNS-Resolver ist.
Nun, Sie werden sich fragen,
warum haben Sie drei DNS-Server,
wenn DHCP nur eine Primäre und eine Zweite handelt?
Ich benutze KeepaliveD,
Genau, dann sieht man es jetzt ja nochmal.
Aber da ist doch alles, jetzt mal blöd gesagt, da ist ja alles so krass HA unten drunter. Proxmox-Dinger, Kubernetes-Cluster drunter. Wenn wirklich der DNS, was ist es denn jetzt eigentlich, wo läuft denn jetzt der Pi-Hole? Läuft der jetzt in einem Kubernetes-Pod oder keine Ahnung.
wenn der Pi-Hole abkackt, wird er dann nicht eh einfach neu gestartet und ist vielleicht mal, whatever, 10 Sekunden weg?
Ist das so schlimm daheim, wenn mal 10 Sekunden der DNS weg ist, der wahrscheinlich eh nie ausfällt?
Also bei mir ist es so, mein Mikrotik-Router macht DNS, der macht natürlich kein Adblocking
oder sowas, der macht aber halt ein paar Namensauflösungen für lokale Services und alles, was nicht
lokale Domain hat, leitet er halt weiter an.
Also ich 11118888 irgendwas.
Und auf dem anderen, jetzt hast du diese Timouts, die zu einem gehen und dann zu zwei.
Also, weil die meisten Applikationen die Primäre preferieren,
habe ich entschieden, zwei DNS-Server für die Primäre zu laden.
Und dann ist mein zweiterer nur ein Instanz.
Nächster Punkt ist Monitoring und Logging.
Es gibt übrigens unter Linux ein Tool, das kann man verwenden,
um immer den DNS-Server zu nehmen, der als erstes antwortet.
Ich habe leider den Namen vergessen.
Da kannst du beispielsweise zwei DNS-Server einstellen
und der nimmt immer die Antwort von dem, der zuerst antwortet.
Also er fragt immer beide an
und nimmt immer die Antwort von dem, der zuerst zurückkommt.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Das ist ein ganz kleines Tool unter Linux.
Das ist...
Ach, Kerbob N?
Ein S...
SD oder sowas?
Name Bench?
Nee, glaub ich nicht.
Gibt es sowas?
Nee.
Nee, äh...
Nee, das ist es nicht.
Ne
Ne ne ne ne
Auch nicht mit DNS Mask
Ne nicht
DNS Mask
ist es nsd
linux
ob nicht
dns martin ist anbauen das meine ich alles nicht
ich habe vergessen wie das ding heißt dns peyer ist es auch nicht weiß nicht mal wie das ding
ist.
Und dieses Jahr habe ich mich ziemlich ernst genommen.
Ich habe mir entschieden, dass, wenn ich eine App aufbauen werde und es in meinem Home-Lab
abhängig werde, das Leichtste, was ich tun kann, ist, Monitoring und Logging zu starten.
Okay, jetzt wird's übertrieben.
Jetzt kommt die 80% der Infrastruktur, die zum Überwachen der Infrastruktur da ist.
Und ich wette mit euch, er hat bestimmt auch ein Monitoring, um das Monitoring zu set up,
zu zu monitoren.
Grafana.
Ich mag Grafana.
Ich finde das super nice.
Also ist für mich auch, finde ich, die beste
so Graf, Graf
Lösung. Es gibt ja noch ein paar andere.
Du kannst beispielsweise in TabX Grafen machen, aber die TabX Grafen sind der letzte Witz gegenüber Grafana.
Dann gibt es von InfluxDB, die haben auch noch sowas ähnliches auf InfluxDB obendrauf.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt. Aber ganz ehrlich, Grafana ist wirklich das Beste.
Loki again, which gives me log storage and ways to query that data.
Then I set up alloy, which is an agent for scraping those logs
and getting them into.
Ach, das war A-Loy nochmal.
Ich wusste, dass es irgendein Agent ist.
Aber konnte A-Loy nicht auch
lokale Metriken?
Ich das wollte ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren imnächst.
... Grafana.
And then I use Grafana to be able to see those logs
and actually query those logs.
It might seem weird to query logs in Grafana,
but that's how it works.
Wow, wieso?
And it actually turns out pretty nice,
because I get log metrics as well.
And you can see, these are all of the logs
from all of the containers that I'm running.
Wisst ihr, was ich letztens für ein Tool gefunden habe
zum Thema Logs, also Lokallogs angucken auf dem Server?
Elnav, kennt ihr das?
Ich hab das letzte Mal kurz ausprobiert.
Ich bin da zufällig drüber gestolpert.
Ich fand das eigentlich echt nice.
Try it out.
Ne, da zeigt es meine IP an.
Ich will mich nicht leaken wieder.
Ja, da kannst du zum Beispiel,
ich glaub, hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
ähm, ja, hier ist eigentlich,
da kannst du quasi mehrere Log-Files
zeitgleich öffnen
und da zeigt die dir dann on the fly an,
wie die Logs reinkommen.
Das ist ganz praktisch, wenn du zum Beispiel deine, was weiß ich,
Warlock, Securelock aufmachen willst,
D-Mask aufmachen willst und SSH-Lock aufmachen willst oder sowas.
Das kann auch tausend andere Sachen,
aber das sah auf den ersten Blick echt ganz cool aus.
Muss ich schon mal in Zukunft mir ein bisschen näher angucken.
Zumal, was für mich ja immer so ein Kriterium ist,
das ist wohl bei Red Hat in den Standard-Repos drin.
Und wahrscheinlich bei Debian auch.
So, das ist ja schon mal immer ein großer Pluspunkt, dass der Kram dabei ist. Was bringen mir die ganzen Tools, wenn die auf Server nicht verfügbar sind?
Wer hat alles zentrales Login im Homelab? Der Techno-Tim. Ich nicht, bin da zu faul für.
Also, wenn da irgendwas rumspackt, ich pflege ja schon mein Zabbix-Lokal nicht richtig.
Wenn dann irgendwas rumspackt, logge ich mich per SSH ein, gucke mir drei Logfiles an,
sehe, woran es liegt, starte was Neues oder reboote und dann geht es wieder.
Und was bringt einem das jetzt?
Wenn man sieht, das ist ja eh,
das ist ja im Business Enterprise Umfeld auch oftmals so,
es wird Gott und die Welt gelockt,
gemetrikt, gemonitort, sonst was
und dann guckst du in den Service rein
und es sind einfach immer
90 Warnings.
Und dann fragst du dich, was ist denn mit den 90 Warnings?
Ach, die sind immer da.
Dann machst du dir, ja, gut,
macht das wirklich Sinn, Gott und die Welt
zu überwachen, wenn das okay ist, dass das halt
Oh, fuck, jetzt hab ich das runtergeschmissen.
Nein, dass es halt kein Problem ist, eigentlich.
Moment, er hat jetzt Logsim Grafana plus noch Dozzle dazu.
kenne ich gar nicht.
Ich dachte, das ist diese,
ich dachte, das ist so ein Docker-Management-
Interface und eigentlich
hat das nichts mit Logs zu tun.
Ja,
SNMP
macht halt das Wenigste.
SNMP macht ja hauptsächlich Netzwerkequipment.
Man kann theoretisch
ja auch
SNMP auf Linux installieren
und Linux-Sachen über SNMP abfragen.
Habe ich aber noch nie im größeren
Stil gemacht und habe ich auch noch nirgendwo
im größeren Stil gesehen.
Chat, habt ihr schon mal erlebt, dass Linux über
SNMP gemonitort wird?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das taugt,
ja? Also ich weiß nur, dass es geht.
Ja?
Also ich rede jetzt nicht irgendwelche
Netzwerkgeräte, wo man
Netzwerkmetriken abfragen will, sondern so Sachen wie
RAM-Usage,
Disk-Usage,
hängende Prozesse und sowas.
weiß gar nicht, ob das
ein großer Aufwand ist oder ob das easy geht
und sowas.
Habe ich noch nie mehr näher angeguckt.
SNMP unter Linux.
der hat der hat moment moment okay natürlich okay macht macht irgendwie sinn man muss
Man muss ja Prometheus da nicht verbiegen zu.
Ja?
Man muss ja, also kann man machen.
Man könnte diesen Blackbox-Exporter benutzen von Prometheus,
um so Sachen zu machen wie Ping-Host ist up, ist down und so was.
Oder mach mal hier einen Wege drauf, ist up, ist down.
Kann man mit Prometheus machen.
aber sowas hier für so reines
Up-Down-Monitoring, Port-Offen-Zu
finde ich das schöner
als da Prometheus für was
zu verbiegen, wofür es eigentlich nicht gedacht ist
Up-Time-Command
das ist was, was sich explizit
an Homelab-Leute richtet
eigentlich ganz cool, ich hatte es auch mal laufen
für eine Weile. Mir hat dann aber
ein bisschen was gefehlt. Zum Beispiel,
dass du keine gescheite History hast, dass du
so Sachen wie Festplattenbelegungen
nicht richtig abfragen kannst und sowas.
Deswegen, ich
hänge nach wie vor auf Zabbix.
Zabbix, und ich habe
auch kein Zabbix Agent installiert.
Ich benutze den Prometheus Node
Exporter mit Zabbix.
Das geht nämlich mittlerweile auch.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Okay, Moment, Moment, geht das restliche Video jetzt nur um Management fürs Management?
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Okay, Prometheus, Prometheus, stell es.
Scrape Metrics from Pi-Hole, put them in Prometheus and then I can see them here in Grafana.
Die Frage ist, guckt er sich diese Dashboards auch an?
Was ist das denn jetzt schon wieder?
It's a great application to see disk health and smart trends across all of my hard drives on TrueNAS.
Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich auch gedacht, dass das dann auch im Grafana drin ist.
Oder gescraped wird.
Gescraped.
Scraped wird.
weil da nochmal ein extra Tool für, weil er hat jetzt Uptime Kuma, Grafana,
Prometheus-Grafana und noch irgendeine Festplatten-Extra-Monitoring-Geschichte.
Er hat doch bestimmt auch noch irgendwie so eine Single Sign-On-Lösung am Start, dass er sich bei den meisten Tools mit dem gleichen Username und Passwort einloggen kann, oder?
Ein eigener Container-Fan von Top, okay.
server so rathen ssg in running and the top you know i might not have access to ssh at the time
so i just running little container of mv top dann auch going here and all see how much i
use doing and that's helpful for trans coding with plaques or ai with some of the work loads
you see here next media and this is a huge category nicht für mich okay jetzt kommt tatsächlich mal
anscheinend was, wo auch
wirklich eine Anwendung läuft, die
benutzt wird.
Natürlich nur, um
Linux-Distributionen runterzuladen.
So I do run Jellyfin, it's pointed at the same media collection that I have for Plex, so if anything ever happens with Plex and they pull the plug, Jellyfin's ready to go.
Next is a couple of companion apps for Plex.
Tautuli is the first one, it gives me Plex stats and activity.
Okay, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich persönlich
sehe den großen Anwendungszweck
für Plex und die ganzen Mediaserver nicht.
Das Einzige, also das haben wir mal so,
okay, das habe ich falsch ausgedrückt.
Ich sehe das schon.
Ich sehe das Anwendungsgebiet schon.
Die Leute, die sich ihre Linux-Distributionen
runterladen über torrent, usenet oder sonst was.
Die müssen die auch irgendwie gucken.
Dafür ist das da.
Also ich verstehe das schon.
Aber ich sehe den Anwendungszweck für mich nicht,
weil ich streame mittlerweile einfach alles nur noch.
Ich streame das entweder über Amazon Prime,
über ZDF ARD Mediathek,
über Join oder über Apple TV.
So, und da ist alles dabei, was man so gucken will.
Ich habe kein Join-Abo.
Ich habe rausbekommen, wenn man eine etwas ältere Join-Version verwendet auf seinem Android-TV,
dann kann die keine Werbung anzeigen, die ist verbuggt.
Das habe ich durch Zufall entdeckt, weil ich habe das irgendwann mal installiert und Updates disabled für Join.
Und seit einem Monat oder zwei Monaten oder so bleibt die App immer kurz hängen und dann weißt du, jetzt will der eigentlich Werbung anzeigen, schafft es dann aber nie Werbung anzuzeigen und der Film geht weiter.
Das heißt, ich werde diese App auch in nächster Zeit nicht upgraden, solange die kaputt ist und die Werbung nicht anzeigen kann.
Also das reicht mir. Ich gucke ja eh nicht so viel.
Okay, ich gucke manchmal...
Ich gucke manchmal Animes, aber die gucke ich nicht über Plex oder sonst wie.
Da gibt es ja glücklicherweise genug
Streaming-Seiten, wo man sich das
angucken kann
Ich müsste mal
frieren Season 2 weitergucken
Da gibt es glaube ich
nur 10 Folgen, die sind schon alle raus
Ich habe es noch nicht mehr geschafft
als mir die ersten 3 Folgen anzugucken
Habe ich schon wieder vergessen, was ist
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das Video fertig ist
Plex können wir mal überspringen, ganz ehrlich
Das interessiert mich nicht großartig
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Ja, da schwören ja die Amis drauf, als quasi Fernseh-Streaming-Geschichte.
ist ja eigentlich ich kann das nicht oft genug sagen was für ein extremer extremer hyper extreme
abfuck alte oldschool so fernsehtechnik ist als richtig krasse abfuck man muss sich das
mal überlegen. Du bezahlst Geld für deinen Fernsehanschluss, für deinen Kabelanschluss,
sagen wir mal. Dann sollst du noch zusätzlich Geld bezahlen für ein paar Sender in HD.
Sollst du auch noch bezahlen.
dann brauchst du eine Smartcard
damit das alles funktioniert
was du dir da schon gekauft und bezahlt hast
was wiederum nur in zertifizierten und den korrekten Geräten funktioniert
und wenn du das alles gemacht hast
dann können sie dir immer noch
bei den Sendern, die du bezahlst
die du schon doppelt bezahlst
in einem nur zertifizierten Gerät anguckst
können sie dir immer noch verbieten
Serien aufzunehmen oder in Aufnahmen vor und zurück zu spulen.
Jetzt mal eine sehr ernst gemeinte Frage.
Warum gibt es Leute, die das überhaupt benutzen?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich würde das im Leben nicht machen.
Ich gucke das einfach nicht.
Und wenn ich Filme gucken will,
dann kaufe ich mir den Amazon Prime und streame den.
Ich kann es nicht verstehen, dass es Leute gibt, die das wirklich benutzen
Hattest du nicht mal TV-Headern?
Ja, hab ich immer noch
Also mein Setup fürs Wohnzimmer
Sieht aktuell so aus
Ich hab hier so ein Ding
Uno
So ein Teil Uno
So ein Teil hier hab ich bei mir im Wohnzimmer
Ich hab aber die Software
die da mitgeliefert wird, gleich runtergeschmissen.
Kompletter Schrott, kannst du komplett vergessen.
Ich habe eine Custom-Linux-Firmware draufgehauen.
Also ich habe mir das Ding auch nur gekauft,
weil das einen 8-fach-Tuner drin hat für Kabelfernsehen.
Und man kann eine SSD reinstecken und sowas.
Dann habe ich eine Custom-Linux-Distribution drauf installiert,
die explizit für diese Sachen gedacht ist.
Und TV-Headend drauflaufen.
TV Headend. An meinem Fernseher habe ich ein Nvidia Shield TV, wo Kodi draufläuft mit dem TV Headend Plugin und darüber wird Fernseher geguckt und Aufnahmen gemacht und sowas.
Und es läuft echt gut. Das einzige Problem, was ich habe, dass so alle drei Monate das Nvidia Shield Tablet einfach random mal freest und man Strom rausziehen muss und Strom wieder reinmachen muss.
Das liegt jetzt aber nicht am Setup, sondern es liegt am Shield-TV.
Max in meinem Airbnb wohnt jetzt.
Ah, exzellent.
Katzenenjoyers.
Hör mal bloß auf mit Magenta-TV.
Ich wollte für meine Mutter Magenta-TV.
Ich war mal ein bisschen gedudelt gerade an, wenn ich laber.
Ich wollte für meine Mutter ein Magenta-TV-Abo holen.
Das kleinste Abo, was es da gab.
Und die guckt so altes Zeug, was es teilweise nicht in der Mediathek gibt,
aber bei Magenta-TV und sowas.
Die guckt zum Beispiel gerne Traumschiff und solche Sachen.
Aber nur die alten Dinger und das gibt es irgendwie bei Magenta-TV.
Ich habe gesagt, ey, weißt du was, wir holen dir einfach ein Magenta-TV-Abo,
oder kannst du alles gucken und dann kündigen wir es wieder.
Und da wollte ich mich da registrieren
und da ging es los, Alter.
Habe ich mich registriert,
habe bezahlt und auf einmal kommt,
ja,
wir können die Zahlung nicht annehmen
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Äh, warum?
Ja, weil
Telefonnummer nicht korrekt ist.
Telefonnummer stimmt nicht.
Da habe ich mir schon gedacht, Alter, Leute, es kann euch doch scheißegal sein, was ich für eine Telefonnummer habe.
Ich habe mich hier registriert, ich bezahle den Monatsbeitrag, ich heiße Peter Keckel oder so oder Peter Blubb oder was auch immer.
Scheiß drauf, ich bezahle es und gut ist, geht mir nicht auf den Sack.
Okay, dann Telefonnummer stimmt nicht.
Also habe ich das noch ein paar Mal gemacht mit irgendeiner Telefonnummer, die er dann gefressen hat.
und dann ging's, dann sah es zumindest so aus,
als dass es geht,
aber es ging nicht. So, und
Moment, wo hab ich mein Handy?
Pass mal auf. Moment, Moment,
ich les es euch mal vor.
Ich les es euch mal vor.
Ich muss mal kurz hier meine E-Mail-App
aufmachen. Sekunde.
Ähm, meine
E-Mail-App spackt rum.
So, suchen nach
ähm, Magenta
suchen wir das einfach mal.
So.
Bestätigung ihrer
Registrierung.
Ähm, nee, warte mal.
Telekom? Ich such mal nach Telekom.
Okay.
Telekom. Wir konnten Ihre
Bestellung nicht annehmen.
Guten Tag,
Peter Keckel.
Es tut uns leid. Wir können Ihre Bestellung
nicht annehmen. Mit der nachfolgend
aufgeführten Daten ist etwas nicht
in Ordnung.
Und jetzt wollen Sie von mir
Dokumentenprüfung fehlgeschlagen.
Ne, ne, ne. Kundenstammdatenprüfung
fehlgeschlagen. Äh, notwendig.
Bitte senden Sie uns
den Personalausweis, ID-Card
oder Reisepass inklusive
Meldebescheinigung für ein Jahr.
Was? Leute, ich will
einfach nur fucking Streams gucken.
Ich will keine Fingerabdrücke
abgeben oder sowas.
Und dann habe ich, wisst ihr, was ich dann als nächstes gemacht habe?
Die nächste E-Mail, die von der Telekom kam, guten Tag.
Mit dieser E-Mail bestätigen wir, dass ihr Telekom-Login gelöscht wurde.
Ich habe dann einfach meinen Account gelöscht und habe mir gesagt,
fickt euch, kriegt ihr halt kein Geld von mir.
Netflix juckt das überhaupt nicht.
Ich heiße bei Netflix, keine Ahnung, irgendwas 0HD XD 3005 oder irgendwie sowas.
und Netflix juckt das überhaupt nicht.
Solange ich bei Netflix rechtzeitig bezahle,
juckt das Netflix nicht.
Ich habe übrigens gerade kein Netflix-Abo,
weil ich nichts zum Gucken habe.
Aber, ähm,
die sind ja komplett hängen geblieben
bei der Telekom, Alter.
Was muss als nächstes?
Speichelprobe,
dass ich Sachen streamen kann,
oder wie?
So, wir gucken das jetzt aber mal fertig.
Das schaffen wir das ja nie.
Ersatz-TV.
Ersatz-TV, Leute.
Ach so, ich dachte, das ist irgendein EPG oder sowas.
der sich an einen Plexi-Tool befindet.
Ich habe viele Tutorials auf Ersatz gesehen, aber das eine,
das mich wirklich herausgefunden hat, war dieses Tutorial, das ich gesehen habe,
um deine eigene MTV zu bauen.
Und so habe ich diese MTV-Kanäle geschaffen.
Ich glaube, das letzte, was ich vorhatte, ist ein eigenes MTV-Modell.
Okay.
Von den 1900ern, wo ich ältere Videos sehen kann.
Und die streamen 24-7.
Sie streamen nicht technisch,
aber wenn ich zu diesem Kanal gehe, beginnen sie zu streamen.
Das gibt dir das alte Gefühl von MTV, als sie Videos spielen.
Na gut, na gut, wer Spaß daran hat, darum nicht.
Ja, Ultimate IP TV.
presenting them to plex.
Now, why do I do that?
I only do this because Plex only allows you to have one source or another
for live TV.
So you got to choose XML or you got to choose, I think,
okay, juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, das werde ich jetzt mal überspringen.
Paperless, das finde ich tatsächlich interessanter.
Real life ops.
I kind of bundle these together.
Paperless habe ich ja auch vor zu benutzen.
This is pretty cool.
Kind of does exactly what it says.
If you have some paper and you want to go digital,
you need a document management system
and you also need some kind of OCR to be able to index that document.
Also wir haben das ja ausprobiert im Stream mit Paperless,
Paperless AI und Paperless GPT.
Ich fand das gar nicht so übel, zumal die AI auf meinem NAS,
sagen wir mal,
brauchbar, brauchbar schnell lief.
Ich hatte, wie viel hatte ich denn so? Um die 10 Talkens pro Sekunde, oder?
Irgendwie sowas, kann das sein? 10 Tokens die Sekunde?
Irgendwie sowas, das war, oder sogar 14?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, es war ganz okay.
Also das fand ich nicht schlecht, die Kombination.
Weil das Paperless OCR selbst war ein bisschen Paintschimp.
Sie können Dokumente uploaden, Tag-Dokumente und dann diese Dokumente indexieren, damit Sie sie suchen können.
Die OCR ist nicht am besten und das ist, wo etwas wie Paperless AI kommt.
Paperless AI ist ein Art Add-on für Paperless, aber es gibt einen lokalen AI-Engine,
zusammen mit einem Vision Model, um Daten aus den Dokumenten zu extrahieren, die viel besser sind als OCR.
Und dann ein paar andere Dinge, die ich mit Paperless bundle, die Paperless empfiehlt,
ist Tika, die Textextraktion für Dokumente macht.
Und dann ist Gotenberg noch einer, der dir hilft, Office und HTML zu PDFs zu konvertieren,
um sie dann in Paperless zu bekommen, was Paperless liebt, PDFs.
Die nächste Sektion sind Docs und Diagramme.
Und das ist, wo ich viele meiner visuellen Werkzeuge benutze.
Ich benutze viel Excalibur, besonders...
Das muss man doch nicht wirklich selbst hosten.
Und selbst wenn, ist das ein easy Web-Service, einfach irgendwo hingeschoben und gut ist.
By the way, ich kann nicht verstehen, warum Draw.io, meiner Meinung nach, haben die sich selbst ein bisschen abgesägt.
ähm
Draw.io war die perfekte
Webseite, ne? Aber nein,
jetzt ist es diagramms.net
Wer diese Entscheidung getroffen hat,
ist auch richtig dumm.
Diagramming tool
a little more structured than Excalibur
You know, if I need to show a lot
of relations for sure.
Oh, was ist das hier?
I'll end up using diagram. It's great for network
diagrams, for sure. Next is Racula
and Racula is a pretty cool diagramming
Okay, das finde ich mega cool.
Aber für mein kleines Rack komplett unsinnig,
weil ich weiß ja sogar aus dem Kopf, wie was in meinem Rack drin steckt.
Aber das sieht richtig nice aus.
Das gefällt mir.
Okay, das hat er laufen,
aber benutzt nicht richtig, würde ich sagen.
Ne, ich habe da keinen sinnvollen Einsatz für.
Ich finde es ein cooles Tool, aber ich habe da auch keinen Sinnvollen Einsatz
bisher für gefunden.
love to see it next post ist which is social scheduling or posting automation so think of
it like a scheduler for posting things on social media das ist ein kalender
ach so was ist das du machst ein post und das geht dann live als youtube community message
auf Facebook, Twitter und
Instagram oder so und auf Reddit.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Na gut, brauche ich nicht.
Aber okay, den Sinn verstehe ich.
use this one kind of test it out but i realize it's not that hard for me to cross post of four
or five different social media platforms if i was a marketer or let's say i was gonna be okay also
benutzt das eigentlich gar nicht richtig jetzt kommt ein homo system zähler wie die individual
creator next ist tatsächlich eines mal wieder der sachen die nicht nur zu managen von management da
sind sondern wirklich benutzt werden automation and security the home automation platform that
Home Assistant.
Ist es auch.
Aber trotzdem finde ich das Beste, was es gibt.
also running ZigBee to MQTT, which allows me to use ZigBee devices that...
Was, was, was sehe ich denn da hier?
Ist das, ist das das neue ZigBee.MQTT oder was?
Ich habe da noch eine alte Version, die sieht nicht so, die sieht nicht so stylisch aus.
...communicate over MQTT back to Home Assistant and then lots of ZigBee devices,
lots of IP devices, all that I tie into here in Home Assistant.
Scripted ist eine wirklich coole App.
Du kannst es sich wie einen Kamerabrück oder einen vollen NVR für dein Home Security System vorstellen.
Ich benutze es für einen Kamerabrück und das erlaubt mir, meine Unify Kameras in HomeKit zu brechen,
damit ich sie als HomeKit-zertifiziert benutzen kann.
Nichts in Protect ist mit HomeKit kompatibel, und so ist Scripted der Brücke, der mir das erlaubt.
Such a great application if you need to tie in unsupported devices into HomeKit
or Google Home or Alexa.
That goes without saying I'm using Unified Protect for my camera
and VR and my home security.
Databases is its own topic because I use quite a few databases across all.
Was anderes hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert.
Also unter acht verschiedenen Datenbanken hätte ich jetzt auch nicht vermutet.
Also Postgres, Databases.
Was ist das denn?
Das sieht aus wie Postgres, nur mit einem schlechteren Logo.
Das ist Databasers.
Postgres Backup.
Ah.
Postgres Backup, okay.
Sag mal, kann man das hier locking ein bisschen...
bisschen hoch stellen
30 minuten oder ganz ehrlich
never warum sollte überhaupt den bildschirm locken
patients one of the databases i use most is postgres postgres ist ein
awesome open source beste an i use it was ist eigentlich so nice wenn man sich
mal überlegt dass man gar nicht richtig versteht warum die leute überhaupt noch
was anderes verwenden. Postgres kann
nahezu alles. Postgres kann ganz
normal standardmäßige,
relationale Sachen.
Timeseries-Datenbank, JSON-Support,
Fulltext-Search,
Trigramm-Fulltext-Search,
alles. Postgres kann alles.
In bestimmten Anwendungsgebieten,
ja, wenn es dann wirklich darum geht,
um das Letzte rauszukitzeln, ist
natürlich was Spezielles besser.
Also, es gibt, du kannst Timeseries
Datenbank in Postgres machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es aber immer noch schneller
und gerade auch
speichereffizienter, so wie das
beispielsweise Prometheus intern macht.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
ist Postgres,
du kannst eigentlich,
ich sag mal, du kannst 98%
der Sachen, die du
datenbanktechnisch brauchst
und was damit zusammenhängt, kannst du
mit Postgres erschlagen.
...
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt, den Unterschied zwischen MariaDB und MySQL noch nie gecheckt.
Ist nicht MySQL mittlerweile auch Oracle?
Und ist MariaDB dann auch Oracle?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es ist schon lange her, dass ich mal MySQL aufgesetzt habe für irgendwas.
Oh, Hackertools, Leute.
Der Klassiker.
PHP My Admin ist der Klassiker schlechthin.
wenn er traut ist ja was ich bei php mal admin cool findet dieses web interface hier das sieht
so ein bisschen so richtig schön nach 2000 aus admin und running that instead die bg ist ein
anderer mann der trainer hat schuldig like die bg it kind of feels like this code but for sequel
but it's missing a ton of features like habe ich das richtig gesehen hat fünf verschiedene
Ich wollte gerade sagen, fünf verschiedene SQL-Frontend-Dinger.
But why?
Even users.
So if you need to connect to a database and just run some SQL,
dbGate will work.
But if you're going to do that, you might...
Wahrscheinlich hat er dann auf dem Desktop noch...
Wie heißt dieses Ding von JetBrains?
DataCrip oder sowas, gell?
...will use Adminer.
Databases or Databases, I'm not sure how you pronounce it,
Der Chat hat mir letztens gesagt,
Olamer ist gar nicht so geil,
ich soll lieber Kobalt-CPP
oder sowas, oder Kobalt-CPP
verwenden.
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Da würde mich in der Tat tatsächlich mal die Hardware drunter interessieren,
worauf er das Laufen hat.
Er sagt ja nichts zum Team.
Rancher.
Ähm, ich muss mich da jetzt mal outen.
Ich benutze keine Kubernetes-Management-UIs.
Wozu?
Cube CTL, alles, was man braucht.
Oh, weißt du, stimmt nicht ganz.
Okay, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Ich hab schon, okay, ich bin schon bei Google ins Webinterface,
hab mir eine Disk rausgesucht und hab die geklont und sowas.
Das hab ich nicht mit Cube CTL gemacht,
das geht auch gar nicht mit kubectl aber so diese sachen hier die pläne sich anzeigen lassen state
full set sich anzeigen lassen was er die tiere warum brauche ich dafür einen web interface
das ist doch mit kubectl alles viel einfacher und besser zu erledigen als
über eine geklicke web interface das verstehe ich nicht
Er hat bestimmt auch Argo CD am Start.
Renovate ist richtig nice.
Renovate ist was, da kannst du beispielsweise checken,
ob in irgendeinem
Textdatei
von dir, das versteht alle möglichen
Formate von Dockerfiles
bis Package.json
Nougat, alles
mögliche,
ob dort
Versionen referenziert sind, vor die es
Updates gibt.
Also Renovate ist
richtig pock.
Das macht dir dann im Zweifelsfall auch ein
Pull-Request auf und sagt, ey, guck mal, gibt's ein Update.
Das ist
richtig gut. Und was halt das richtig Gute ist, das versteht alles Mögliche. Helm-Yammels,
Kubernetes-Yammels, Docker-Files, NPM, Cargo-Tommels, das versteht alles. Renovate ist richtig nice.
It will open pull requests against my Git-Repo, where I approve them, and then once merged,
they get deployed with Flux. So, pretty cool. Ah, er verwendet Flux, nicht Argo-CD.
Und was wird jetzt auf S3 gespeichert?
Minio ist ein super komplexes Setup, was er am Start hat.
Ich verstehe das ja, aber man kann sich einfach auch ein Git Repo klonen,
editieren, commit machen und pushen. Warum braucht man Visual Studio Code im Browser nur dafür?
Also cool, dass es geht, aber.
Ja, GitLab hat das. Unser GitLab auf der Arbeit hat das auch. Das hat diesen normalen Editor und dann diese Web IDE auf Visual Studio Code Basis.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Das habe ich zwar nicht selbst gehaust,
aber das benutze ich auch manchmal.
So für irgendwelche Sachen wie
UID Base64
und sowas.
Das frage ich mich auch.
Aber gut, wenn dich natürlich lokaler Speed von deinem Netzwerk interessiert, dann bringt
dir das nichts, wenn es im Internet ist.
Wobei ich da halt sagen muss, wenn ich lokal Netzwerk testen will, IPerf, fertig. Warum sowas?
Genau, sehe ich auch so.
Das habe ich ja nicht in dem Sinn selbst gehostet mit dem Netboot XYZ Selfhosting.
Ich habe ja meinen eigenen PXE-Server am Start, der unter anderem das Netboot ISO raushaut.
Aber da freue ich mich immer, wenn ich was PXE booten kann.
Und man muss natürlich sagen, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, machen wir das mal kurz.
Nicht VeraCrypt, VMware.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, man muss natürlich sagen, dass, ja, machen wir mal hier PXE-Boot.
Man muss natürlich sagen, dass, ich starte jetzt mal PXE-Boot,
dass mein Boot-Icon natürlich deutlich besser ist als der Standard-Icon.
Oder?
Also ich würde sagen, mein PXE-Boot-Icon ist eindeutig besser als das Standard-Schwarz-Weiße.
Das ist ein KI-Bild, ja?
Ich weiß, bevor ihr mich jetzt darauf hinweisen müsst.
Aber so sieht mein PXE-Boot aus.
Und man kann auch direkt Netboot XYZ booten, wenn ich irgendwas starten will, was ich hier nicht drin habe.
Aber ich sage mal so, die meisten Sachen, die ich brauche, habe ich hier drin.
Aber wenn ich was anderes brauchen sollte, kann ich auch immer noch sagen, ja, ich will Netboot XY starten.
Das starte dann irgendwann.
Und dann kann ich hier auch sagen, keine Ahnung, hier Live-CDs.
Oh, jetzt buggt VMware wieder rum.
Und dann kann ich hier, keine Ahnung, hier Elementary OS oder so.
Ja, bam.
Zack.
Dann startet Elementary OS.
Netboot.
Also ich chainboote quasi von meinem PXE nach Netboot, wenn ich es brauche.
Dann können wir hier Elementary OS Live-CD netbooten.
So sieht's aus. Okay.
Wollte ich bloß mal zeigen, weil
das finde ich sehr nice.
Lokalen PXE-Server.
Der kann auch unterscheiden...
Ja, ich benutze Elementary
OS auch nicht. Der kann auch unterscheiden
zwischen BIOS-Boot und
UEFI-Boot.
Was ist PXE?
Da kannst du übers Netzwerk...
Also da brauchst du keinen lokalen USB-Stick oder
CDs oder sonst was. Da kannst du übers Netzwerk booten.
Wie man gerade...
Okay, Moment mal.
Ich zeige es einfach nochmal.
Also, guck mal.
Wenn du eine Kiste starten willst...
Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes.
Ich stelle das jetzt mal um auf das Klassische, was die Leute noch kennen.
BIOS.
Also quasi Netboot XYZ...
Ja, ja, Moment.
Netboot XYZ benutzt IPXE.
Ich kann aus meinem PXE Netboot XYZ auch starten.
Aber das ist noch davor.
Du brauchst auch keine Festplatte, ne?
Gut, guck mal hier. Wir starten das Ganze jetzt.
Okay, jetzt.
Genau, jetzt starte Netboot.
Ich hab Escape gedrückt.
Das war, glaube ich, keine gute Idee.
Ja, das war blöd.
So, nochmal starten.
So, jetzt macht der Netzwerk Boot.
Gut.
Oh Gott, VMware backt wieder rum, Alter.
Was soll der Scheiß?
VMware, nicht rumnerven.
VMware, hallo, please.
Mach mal VMware-Dinger.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was VMware gerade wieder treibt.
Aber ihr habt ja eben gesehen, dass es funktioniert.
Geil, oder?
Das fand ich mir gut.
Jetzt zeigt es wieder nichts an.
Ey, wie beschissen...
Also, vor allem, wer macht echt so einen Wettbewerb,
wie schlecht möchtest du sein, ja?
Ach so, da dran liegt es.
das buggt, wenn Accelerate 3D Graphics
an ist.
Seit neuestem. Seit vor immer
25 oder so.
Das buggt. Ich sehe es schon
wieder, dass das buggt. Das buggt schon wieder rum.
Okay, keine Ahnung, warum das jetzt aus
irgendwelchen Gründen nicht funktioniert.
Eben hat es nur funktioniert.
Whatever.
Okay.
Jetzt will er nix mehr. Jetzt hat er keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Nee, vor allem auf der Arbeit ist besser.
Ich stell das mal wieder um auf EFI.
Macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn, weil es geht ja beides.
Hä? Jetzt startet CacheOS.
Das wollte ich doch überhaupt nicht. Ich wollte PXE booten.
So.
EFI-Netzwerkboot, geht das jetzt wenigstens?
Das funktioniert jetzt.
Oder?
Okay, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Warum das mit BIOS-Boot nicht geht?
Guck, du kannst jetzt hier über das Netzwerk booten.
Du brauchst da weder eine Festplatte noch einen USB-Stick.
Sagen wir, ey, ich würde gerne den Windows, den Windows-Mint, den Linux-Mint-Installer booten.
Kannst hier auswählen.
Zack.
Dann lädt er sich das ISO runter, entpackt es in RAM und startet.
Und dann hast du hier dein Linux Mint gestartet über das Netzwerk.
Brauchst du hier keinen USB-Stick mehr machen.
Eigentlich ganz nice.
Dauert natürlich ein bisschen länger, weil er sich den Kram erst alles runterladen muss.
Aber er ist halbwegs geschwind, weil er sich lokal bei mir...
Also ich hab's ja auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Und da geht das eigentlich ganz gut von der Geschwindigkeit her.
Das Mint habe ich lokal auf dem Raspberry Pi liegen.
Ich lade mir das einmal die Woche, lade ich mir neuesten ISOs runter.
Es dauert jetzt natürlich ein bisschen, weil die Mint ISO ein paar Gig groß ist, wie du hier neben siehst.
Guck, wir haben schon fast zwei Gigabyte.
Aber wir lassen es jetzt einmal durchlaufen, dass man sieht, dass es funktioniert.
Warum das BIOS-Boot nicht mal geht, verstehe ich gerade nicht.
Okay, 2,8 Gig oder so ist das Linux Mint ISO groß.
Dementsprechend braucht es natürlich auch viel RAM, weil das jetzt alles in RAM geladen wird.
Also für Kisten mit nur 4 Gig RAM oder so ist das nichts.
da kriegst du Probleme
so guck jetzt habe ich das ISO runtergeladen
entpackt es in RAM und jetzt startet er
das Linux
und zack hast du dein Linux Mint am Start
wenn es denn dann funktioniert
ja guck da ist es
Linux Mint
Und jetzt machen wir wieder aus.
Ich probiere jetzt nochmal was.
Ich frage mich, warum das BIOS-Boot gerade nicht geht.
Wundert mich.
Weil der müsste sich ja eigentlich per DHCP was holen.
Aber der backt rum.
Stimmt auch irgendwas.
Guck mal, wie schnell der da schon rumrödelt.
keine Ahnung, da ist irgendwas kaputt
bei dem BIOS Boot
wir probieren das nochmal
das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das
an der Anfragen-MWR liegt
new virtual machine
next, later
next
next, next, next
bridged
Next.
Weiter.
So, hier können wir jetzt noch einstellen.
Äh, nee, können wir noch nicht einstellen.
Finish.
Das da, okay. Und BIOS.
BIOS, okay. So, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt...
Ah, jetzt nervt nicht.
Ah ja, jetzt steht es da.
Nee.
Aus irgendwelchen
Gründen geht das DHCP
booten gerade nicht
mit BIOS?
Warum?
But why?
No DHCP or Proxies?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
SSH.
Hm.
Was hatte der nochmal für eine IP?
55.
PXE Champ.
Wir müssen mal kurz ins Log gucken.
Tail.
Äh
War
Ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen Musik an
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz checken
Video ist ja eh fast fertig
Das interessiert mich jetzt, was er für Schmerzen hat
War, Log
TFTP, ne, DNS Mask
Oder auch nicht
Warte mal, es klopft
So, ich bin wieder da.
Ich muss jetzt mal checken, warum das mit DHCP nicht funktioniert.
Wir machen das jetzt mal anders.
System CTL Stopp DNS Mask.
Ich mach das ja mit DNS Mask.
Und jetzt starten wir mal den DNS Mask von Hand.
Achso.
Kill all DNS Mask.
Kann ich nicht irgendwie sagen, DNS Mask?
Kann man das nicht irgendwie von Hand starten?
Hallo? Äh...
Darf ich nicht sagen, DNS-Mask, irgendwie das ist der No-Demon?
Oder sowas? No-Demon.
Minus D.
DNS-Mask minus D.
Okay, so.
Er listet hier.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, was er sagt,
wenn ich hier PXE bote.
Der gibt dem keine IP, seht ihr das?
Warum denn nicht?
Moment.
Mein.
Mein Router gibt dem keine IP.
Der DHCP-Server selbst gibt ihm eine IP, oder?
Hä?
Broadcast Response?
Antwortet doch, oder?
Das check ich nicht.
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Das ging doch die ganze Zeit.
Ich habe da seit Wochen nichts dran gemacht.
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Wim, ETC, DNS-Mask,
PONF.
Ja, guck, das ist total übersichtlich.
Da hat sich seit Wochen nichts getan dran.
Und man sieht ja auch, dass der antwortet
Aber der kriegt irgendwie keine IP
Hm
Die Lease ist voll
Ja, aber dann müsste der doch
Dann dürfte der doch per
Per EFI-Boot auch nichts kriegen
Ich habe gerade eine neue VM angelegt
Das verstehe ich nicht
Keine Ahnung
Das ist bestimmt
Leute, ich wette mit euch, das ist irgendein
Vmware-Bug
Ich mache jetzt mal mein Nass an
Und dann starten wir mal da die Kiste
So
Jetzt starten wir mal hier
Proxmox
Okay, das ist noch nicht da
Ich würde jetzt warten, bis die Proxmox-Kiste gestartet ist
Ich muss dann übrigens auch Mittag essen, wa?
Wird echt Zeit
Du willst Hunger
Die Netzwerkkarte ist auf Bridged
Ja, das ist komisch
Man sieht ja auch den Request hier ankommen
Auf dem Raspberry Pi, ne
Es gibt Kartoffelsalat und Würstchen
Also kein Lachs mit Nudeln
Ja, kann mein Nas jetzt nochmal booten?
Wird es heute nochmal was?
Na, Naschamp?
Warum geht denn das jetzt nicht?
Ey, sag mal, ist hier irgendwas im Arsch gerade oder so?
Netzwerktechnisch.
Ey, Netzwerk ist link, ist ab.
Was ist hier los?
Ah, jetzt.
Okay, da ist es. Alles gut.
Hat jetzt alles eine ganze Weile gebraucht.
Ja, ja.
Okay, ähm...
Ich bastel auch gerade irgendwas,
weil mir aufgefallen ist, meine Kiste booten nicht mehr richtig.
Hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun heute.
So, jetzt haben wir Proxmox gestartet.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wenn ich jetzt hier
eine Proxmox-Kiste anlege, sehen wir mal,
ob das ein VNW-Bug ist oder nicht.
Okay, Proxmox-Kiste.
Nehmen wir doch einfach mal
Was ist das denn
O-M-V
Temp4M klingt doch gut
So Start
Boot
Ups
Äh ja
Ich muss restarten
Weil
Ich habe nicht rechtzeitig Escape gedrückt für Netzwerkboot.
Jetzt Escape.
So.
PXE.
Funktioniert.
BIOS-Boot.
Hä?
Okay, Leute.
Kein blassen Schimmer.
Was da vor allem wer wieder für Schmerzen hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Vor allem hat er gerade irgendwie keinen Bock.
Komisch.
Nun gut, Chat.
Wir haben das Video vom Techno-Tim ja fertig.
Aber noch nicht ganz.
Das gucken wir jetzt zumindest noch fertig.
Dann vergesse ich Spaß.
Ja, Netbooty XYZ ist cock.
Was hat er da?
Ich denke, der hat dafür PNAT am Start.
Das Tool sieht wirklich aus wie 1992, oder?
Das ist übrigens der Grund, solche Sachen sind der Grund, warum aus Browsern einfach nichts Altes rausgeschmissen werden kann.
Zu Recht, ja.
Digital Shutdowns, wenn die Batterie unter einem bestimmten Punkt ist,
damit ich keine Daten korrigieren kann.
Ein bisschen schwer zu konfigurieren, aber wirklich toll, wenn du das machst.
Peanut ist etwas, das ich letztes Jahr erstellte,
aber es ist eine Web-UI für NutServer.
Denk ein bisschen wie eine moderne Art, NutServer und Daten zu betrachten.
Eines der Dinge, die ich letztes Jahr wünschte,
war, dass Peanut tatsächlich seine Daten auflöst.
Nun, das ist das, was ich dieses Jahr bekommen habe.
Peanut kann jetzt InfluxDB oder Prometheus schreiben.
Und ich bin hier, also kann ich das Daten auswählen und dann es in Grafana hochladen.
Ich denke, das war eine tolle Architekturentscheidung von der Entwickler Peanut,
InfluxDB oder Prometheus zu nutzen, anstatt deine eigene Datenbase-Solution zu entwickeln.
Gute Arbeit.
Gut auch, dass beides ist.
Okay, da haben wir es.
Okay, also im Prinzip wieder wie gehabt, wie ich auch vermutet habe,
Er self-hostet, das Self-Hostens-Willen, ganz viel Management um Management und Monitoren zu monitoren und irgendwie drei Anwendungen, die wirklich laufen.
Was?
Das bekannteste KI-Modell ist, ja das kenne ich.
Aha.
größere Performanceoptimierung.
Aha, so ist das.
Äh, mein NAS,
by the way,
hat sich
aus irgendwelchen Gründen
äh
Ich hab dem doch gerade gesagt,
Power Off.
Das hat keinen Bock, sich runterzufahren.
Okay, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Wenn sich das nicht runterfährt...
Ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Das ist, weil er noch auf ein Timeout wartet,
bis sich die Open Media Vault vor ihm ausschaltet.
Oder? Moment, die Open Media Vault vor ihm ist...
Ach doch, ich dab die Open Media Vault vor ihm.
Ist doch an.
Das ist das Problem.
Da muss der erst auf ein Timeout warten.
Jetzt hat es sich nämlich ausgeschaltet.
Guck, das muss erst auf einen Timeout warten,
bis sich das runtergefahren hat.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut, Chat, schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Nice Stream, genau vier Stunden.
Ich werde jetzt was futtern.
Ich habe übertrieben Hunger.
Mal gucken, ob wir uns später sehen.
Schauen wir mal.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.